so youtube is always
changing and updating and in this video
i'm going to be talking about
five cool new youtube features and
updates that can help you get more views
on your videos because here's the thing
when you look at your data
and your analytics and the information
that youtube
gives you you can make more informed
decisions
you can make data driven decisions and
remember
that what gets measured gets improved
and so as we're looking at your channel
as we're looking at your videos
we can start to get insights so our next
video can be our best video and get more
views
uh every single time we post and um
we're gonna be talking about five of
those features in this video plus
youtube is making some new updates and
changes as well
so i'm excited to get into those but if
you're new to the show my name is sean
cannell this is coffee with cannell let
me know where you're watching from smash
the like button if you're fired up
and in the first 15 minutes
of the show we go through content with
these five tips and then i bring
you on to answer your questions about
business
social media youtube and life and so uh
it's good to see
iron worth wolf zach sam becca in the
house
big dog plate let's dive into the
content and today's episode is brought
to you by
the think marketing podcast that's our
weekly podcast and let me know
if you've checked it out yet it's
available on every platform audio
on apple spotify google and then of
course the video podcast
on our new youtube channel called think
marketing and every week
we are helping you learn the behind the
scenes strategies and tips
for growing your influence and making
money with youtube and online
video and so make sure to check out
links in the description below or the
comments
and get subscribed to the think
marketing
podcast it's the tuesday ritual every
tuesday
there's a new episode and so let me know
if you've been
checking out the think marketing podcast
and um
let me ask you a question how often do
you look at youtube analytics and what
questions do you have
about youtube analytics let me know in
the comments
and here's tip number one and that is
when
are your viewers on youtube and so i'm
gonna be taking you behind the scenes
of the analytics on our youtube channel
think
media and here's some of these new
features okay so when you get inside of
your youtube
studio sometimes it can feel
intimidating there's a lot going on
there's a lot of information
it really goes down over on the left
side of
the screen inside of your youtube studio
and what you want to click on is
analytics
and what you want to click on up at the
top there's overview and reach and
engagement you want to click on
audience and what's cool is there's this
newer feature of when your viewers are
on youtube do you see these purple lines
here on screen
and this is cool because this is telling
you
your peak times of viewership so for
think media
i'm recording this video on a tuesday
and
at let's see this is local time it says
your local time
at 3 am some of your viewers are on
youtube is what it's describing my
channel as
at 5 00 am many of the viewers are on
youtube
by seven very many of your viewers
are on youtube i like how they worded
that and then it's very many
the peak hours are really from 7 a.m my
local time i'm
streaming from las vegas west coast
uh pacific time and then it starts
to drop off at 11 a.m and by one
many of your viewers on youtube by two
it's down to some and it's like some
throughout the night it looks like
few at obviously 2 a.m and
uh like 1am it's few
and then throughout the day there's kind
of a consistency but we obviously see
this range here so what does this
information tell us well it tells us a
lot
it tells us when you should publish
and upload your videos maybe even
schedule upload
your videos now disclaimer you might not
have this data yet
for a couple reasons the first one is
you might not have enough data let me
know how many videos have you posted on
youtube if you've only posted two videos
and you only you don't have very many
subscribers yet there's not a lot of
data yet
so you're always first moved when you're
starting youtube is to punch fear in the
face
punch perfectionism in the face press
record
and post your first 30 to 50 videos with
your head down
not worried too much about analytics
just worried about
getting in the game and pressing record
but let me know what insights you can
see if you can open up your analytics
even during this stream
when you look at this on the back end so
pretty powerful right
and this uh one of our favorite things
we're actually gonna be uploading a
video
is about all the tips around scheduling
your videos
i think that scheduling your videos is
one of the best practices you can have
for putting it out of course you can
always publish it but scheduling it
helps it get done the day before and it
helps you
really think through everything to make
sure everything's right and then it also
allows you to potentially
upload because what you'd want to do is
upload before really the rise
so for example we released the think
marketing podcast today
every tuesday it comes out at 3 a.m
our time because that's 6 a.m on the
east coast here in the u.s
and we want to be a part of people's
commutes if you wanted to listen to the
audio or the video
and then it allows it to be there if you
will all morning long
and so we post before the rise a lot of
times and we also use tools like vid iq
to get the same data and now youtube is
giving us this data a lot of times on
think media most of our videos are
schedule uploaded
so they're done at least a day before
and they're scheduled for
5 a.m or 4 a.m or 3 a.m and here's the
deal man
nobody on the think media team is
getting up to do that i mean i got up at
four today
because i'm a new dad and you know life
is life and i just
couldn't sleep any longer i actually
started getting some stuff done
but usually i'm still in bed but the
video is coming out and then as soon as
i get up i can answer comments and
engage
so that's tip number one it's on the
audience tab of your youtube studio and
it tells you when your viewers
are on youtube you may need to get more
videos posted you may need your channel
to age up a bit because sometimes
youtube is releasing
these features in waves oh let me know
if you already have this feature
on the back end of your youtube channel
hit like if you found that valuable and
let's go into the next
tip tip number two is audience interest
now this one is super cool and again
you may need more traffic you may need
more growth before you see this one
but this one's really powerful if we
scroll down a little bit here on the
right side now
it says other videos your audience
watched okay can you think about how you
could use this
you start to understand your audience
better
you maybe could get some video ideas and
here's the key if you want to win on
youtube to the degree that you
understand your audience's problems
and ambitions and create content
that addresses their problems and their
ambitions
when you create the right content at the
right time
on the right topic with the right title
and the right thumbnail
it's very powerful so so being informed
and making data driven decisions and
insights from youtube studio analytics
youtube uh the back end of youtube you
can you can get
various video ideas so this is kind of
cool in the last seven days youtube is
now saying
here's what are some of the other videos
that uh
think media fans and community are
watching so
a lot of stuff peter mckinnon but stuff
on the new dji
rs2 um easy tricks for photography and a
lot of times omar on the think media
teams doing photography stuff so
maybe that's like okay you know we've
been making
10 tips on photography maybe we could do
our easy tip on photography see what i'm
saying and
here's the deal we know the psychology
of the viewer because the viewer
that that is watching this video wants
to learn tricks for photography do you
see how powerful that is now again
you may not have this feature yet but
keep posting keep building
and uh even for a while i mean think
media is over a million subscribers
and it took a while for this to get
updated so be patient
uh three minutes of no bs straight to
the point flash photography from manny
ortiz
so i saw that one and i thought it's
really good title what if i did like
five minutes of no bs youtube strategies
that you can use right now
did you just see how i used his title
formula like it's a different video but
like
three minutes you know what i mean like
it's a really good title and then you're
like okay it even informs the content
i'm gonna create even if i don't create
a video on photography
and then um so i'm getting some insight
into
you know again the viewership the
psychology there's three pages here
uh i'm also seeing what is hot in tech
now this is
knowing your niche right or knowing your
niche
man a lot of people are talking about
this dji rs2
maybe i should talk about that as well
you know a lot
people are talking about the m50 mark ii
i haven't even talked about it yet but
we're going to be talking about it
on think media um you see maybe other
channels catherine manning
we've collaborated with catherine we had
her she's that growth video live
so maybe there's people you want to
collaborate with or looking at again
what she's doing
best usb mics maybe that is on our list
of things to do
okay we got uh my man nick nimmin and
his new channel nick nimming clips is is
on there so that's interesting and then
getting some insights and uh lots of
stuff on the the new dji gimbal so again
it's like there's the writing there um
the m50 mark ii again
something that we have videos coming on
that soon of course apple iphone 12.
so that is another feature that helps
you make data driven
decisions so let me know have you been
looking at your analytics are you
intimidated by analytics
that is the audience interest
panel other videos your audience has
watched and it's when you click on
analytics on the left side
and you click audience at the top of the
page under your channel analytics that
is how you get
to that particular area
um okay let me know if you're getting
value out of this video so far and
let me know uh how often you look at
analytics danny says it's the first time
i've been looking at him
and so um this should be helpful and i
want to encourage you again
what gets measured gets improved even if
it's intimidating to look at your
analytics just go in there
deer in headlights and just look around
because eventually you start
like neo in the matrix right it took him
a while to like take the blue pill or
the red pill i forget which one
and then eventually he was like oh i can
dodge bullets man
you know and it's bullet time and he's
dodging bullets and and he's
now he's like i'm not even intimidated
by you he sees that the whole thing is
just math and like
the green lines of the of the code is
going down and he's able to
manipulate the matrix if you want to
manipulate the youtube algorithm right
and begin to understand things you got
to look at your analytics
you got to make data-driven decisions
and so just spend time
just commit to me that you're going to
start looking at your analytics more
what gets measured gets improved you
know if you want to
make progress in losing weight you want
the more often you measure yourself on a
scale
the better because you know if you're
making progress or not you know if what
you did
is helping you progress i did this thing
called 75 hard i didn't make it
i got about 35 days and then we had our
conference grow with video live
and one of the things they had us do is
take daily progress
pictures kind of annoying so every
single day you're like in the shower
like
in the shower waterproof phone like in
the mirror you know
like taking progress pictures you make
it look really bad on day one because
you're like i want it to actually like
look better by the end
whatever why are you taking daily
progress pictures
because what gets measured more often
will get
improved more quickly so
when you're looking at your analytics if
you're studying your audience retention
studying what's happening uh with your
uh time of day other videos
you're gonna make better decisions
you're going to make better videos and
you're going to get more views more
subscribers and grow your channel faster
which brings us to tip number three
which is how viewers found this video
this is pretty awesome i
just noticed this and youtube studio is
always
always up to something they're always
cooking and uh
they're always adding new things and so
what you can do
here i am on the home page is you can
look at
your latest video performance our latest
video is pretty niche let me
let me look at this uh this video over
here
now here it is so there's always been
like traffic sources
but now underneath the main analytics
okay there is this traffic sources
how viewers found this video
it's very insightful let me zoom in here
and we'll get we'll get crazy
so this tells us some things in
particular
this video how viewers found this video
youtube recommendations was the biggest
one 58
so the question is like where do views
come from the question is you know
where's traffic coming from and
17 000 views of this video which is up
so the green arrow
says like this video is crushing your
typical range it actually tells you you
normally get
1.8 1800 views to 3 600 views
this one already has 17 000 and is
getting tons of views this one's kind of
taking off
so youtube recommendations but then it
breaks it down and it's saying
40 of the traffic on this video is from
the home page
it's actually telling you in much more
granular detail i just noticed this let
me know if you've seen this one before
it's it's they are the cool thing about
youtube studio
even if you love the old analytics they
are gone you know
now it's all youtube studio is they can
add more things to it and they're
constantly tweaking it and adding
more granular insights but even up next
which i believe up next is you know when
a video ends
and then it recommends another video and
so
5 600 views so far have come from up
next
of maybe a think media subscriber or a
think media viewer
that finishes the video and then this
video is out and
it's getting a good click-through rate
it's getting good you know audience
retention etc
so youtube recommends it as up next
that's
youtube recommendation that's a lot 60
of the traffic that shows you
that when a video gets sucked into the
youtube algorithm
when a video is being recommended by
youtube
more so than search more so than ranking
more so
that it really can take off okay
so this this makes you think okay well
can i double down on this topic
can i um you know what can i learn from
this as i'm studying this
this also speaks to how important
subscribers are and that might not come
as
much news to you because you're like
yeah i want more subscribers let me know
maybe one of your goals is to get a
silver play button or a gold play button
but you don't want to just get
subscribers for subscribers sake
you want people that are subscribed to
your channel
that enjoy your content and you want
your content to be consistent enough
that you never upload a video that your
subscribers didn't subscribe for
which actually today arguably we
uploaded a very niche video on think
media
and that's why it's not doing very good
because a lot of people are like oh that
doesn't it's not relevant for me it's
about
how a wireless gimbal setup for churches
like that's very specific versus like
canon m50 or versus like tips for
youtube like how broad the topic is like
how relevant it is to your subscriber
base they might have subscribed for one
niche topic you talked about once
and you haven't even talked about it
since so they're not clicking on any of
your videos
so by studying this what i want you to
see
is that youtube is recommending this on
the home page and
up next and then another 15 is from the
subscription feed
so that is the power of having a base of
subscribers
even if the title wasn't great now
obviously the title resonated with
the viewer the subscriber and the
thumbnail was clickable but
like there's not gonna be many people
clicking on your videos in the
subscription feed if you don't have very
many subscribers so it just speaks to
the power right
of building a base one subscriber at a
time
don't despise small beginnings and so
that's where another 4
500 views came from then notifications
and you can actually
see uh how many people have
notifications on your channel i'll show
you that as just a bonus it's not one of
the tips today
channel pages i've noticed that as uh
think media has grown over the years
channel pages
is kind of like i see it on my smart tv
like i want to encourage you to be more
of a youtube consumer
you're like bro my wife does not want
you to say that i already watch too much
youtube okay listen
i want you to consume more youtube as a
student
and think about consuming youtube on
mobile consuming youtube on a smart tv
so when we go to our smart tv with our
apple tv and i go to youtube
and i look there's different on the home
page it's very fascinating
the way youtube groups videos together
i'm actually logged in with like my sean
cannell account
so i see think media and think media
becomes like a cluster of channel pages
it's like videos by think media where
like youtube creates kind of this own
playlist thing to it
and the most popular videos are in that
uh
are in that channel pages kind of
playlist um channel pages of course also
like i don't even know if i'm describing
channel pages right channel pages being
like
maybe your home page or people going
through your videos and clicking on your
videos
and then other and you can also click
see all right
and you can get into what's called
advanced analytics
and it even gives you like it's so
clearly obvious though here the blue
the blue top one is the browse features
is like the thing as it comes to traffic
but then down here there's also you know
definitely some other ones
and you know this video was more of like
a click through
and watch it uh browse features type of
a video and less of like a ranking type
video so different videos have different
strategies now
really quick uh let me show you where
you can see
uh your notifications which
is gonna be here i believe
under uh uh here you go on the right
side under reach
bell notification sent 100 percent um so
126 000 subscribers got that
notification click through rate
uh view notification from bells and
that's actually not the one that i
wanted to look at
maybe it's actually back on my macro
analytics it is
so if you go to macro analytics and come
to audience over here subscriber bell
notifications
you can see that 16 of think media
subscribers
have all notifications turned on and
then nine percent
have turned on uh who turned on all
notifications and some just turned on
notifications
um and so typical it's 10 to 30 percent
so i'm kind of right in the middle there
and typical here is five to 20. so again
a little bit low but kind of in the
middle and so anyways uh that's
on the right side you can see
notifications i know i'm already
throwing a lot at you
um but let me know if you're getting
value and what your aha moment's been so
far smash the like button if you would
be so kind
and let's talk about
tip number four and then we'll be
bringing on some people for q a in just
a bit
update your phone apps so
did you know there's a youtube studio
app let me know actually in the comments
did you know there's a youtube studio
app not a youtube app on your phone
update that one as well but youtube
studio is a separate app
for you the youtube creator it's the
best way
to get all of the data that you want to
get about your channel
so if i go to youtube studio
i can actually see um a lot
not it's not as good as the desktop
analytics but they're constantly
improving this as well
with new features and new updates it's
also a really
a little bit of a better way to answer
comments in a more streamlined way so i
see my latest videos performance
i can um click on video performance and
get a ton of data you can't really read
that there
but it says views on today's video over
on think media views are 33
lower because of less subscriber
interest
like subscribers are less interested in
today's topic okay
views in the first seven hours and this
is constantly being updated but to get
the most
current updates you want to make sure
your apps are updated so have you
downloaded
the youtube studio this is the google
play store you can get it in the apple
store
let me know if you even knew there was a
youtube studio uh app
uh homie's like i've been missing out
man uh a couple people already have it
fixin has it kristen's got it awesome so
uh
and then let me ask you is it updated so
i recently just updated
also my youtube app and i noticed that
like chapters
weren't showing up on mobile but if you
update your app you can start seeing
chapters
comments are in like a different place
um they're making some updates to the
youtube studio app
for optimizing your videos adding
descriptions and tags and making it
easier so these things are always
progressing so that's just kind of a tip
there's new updates coming to the
youtube studio make sure you have both
apps and both apps are updated no matter
what kind
of phone you have
and uh again you can look at
uh revenue and and where traffic's
coming from and you can look at uh
comments and as well as all your
notifications and things that are
happening
pretty cool okay and then tip number
five this one's not really new but i
wanted to show you this if you haven't
seen it before
there's quick comment responses quick
comment responses so what's kind of cool
about this is you can go into
number one they continually make
youtube studio hopefully better
for replying to people
uh and a user interface so for example
watch this
on channel comments this is my whole
channel now right
now again if you're just starting you're
like when no one's commenting yet well
you got to keep posting
but eventually you get comments and
eventually you might be able to manually
go through them but this puts them all
in one place but watch this
contains questions did you know that
like contains questions
so now you can actually filter across
your new and old videos
and uh and it crashed but you know
theoretically and another way to do that
let me actually
search and i'm going to search for
question since maybe that didn't work
but even if it did people right here
they might say
uh here's my question you know my
question is
people say 74 years
christian songwriker i have my question
you know whatever it is thanks for
answering my questions
so i'm searching a word to actually go
through all my comments
we could try that again let's see if
contains questions maybe works we'll
give youtube another shot here loading
up
so here you go but how do you put the
links for videos in the middle
um and that maybe is something to just
reply to
or maybe that is something to make a new
video about right so now you're making
audience informed video decisions okay
now what's also powerful is
that you can just quickly reply to
people hi
you know hey now that's not the quick
reply and uh
throw that a little thumbs up but like
so this is uh
you human woo in short the mark iii is
better for photography
uh goes through some over eating issues
over autofocus so i'm gonna heart that
comment
and say very true do you see that auto
reply very true
so youtube gave me three options and i
was able to just click very true
like that's pretty intelligent because i
do agree
with what she's saying they they read my
mind
like so they're doing their best and if
you go down okay hoping to utilize my ba
and communications to become successful
on youtube
we enjoy sharing our lives tips tricks
in the world with you all
uh best of luck reply now this really
becomes powerful when you're at scale
and trying to
reply to different people and again you
might look at your three choices and go
mom
none of those are relevant you type one
out and you might not get the
recommendations in this case
and you could say uh the jesus mirror
i started my channel a year ago i make
christian faith and rich videos with
self-care lifestyle videos helping
people who find out who they are
um you know awesome thanks for being a
part of the think media community
awesome sean you're just gonna answer
comments while we wait here okay you get
it uh did i smell community right okay
so and then you can just answer those
comments of course
here in the channel comments area in a
bulk way
across your channel but those quick
comment responses
are nice for just again i know you got
stuff going on in your life man maybe
you got a new baby
my baby's coming up on one month old
sean bradley candle
i'm looking for ways to go a little bit
quicker with my projects with my tasks
and so that's kind of a cool feature
from youtube
now coming soon is a
key moments for audience retention
feature
i don't have this yet so to encourage
you if you're like sean i have none of
these things all right well keep posting
right
and they'll be added to your channel
especially as you build up traffic
momentum
and growth and if you haven't subscribed
to the creator insider channel i'll link
that up in the comments below
so creator insider is when youtube tells
us about the latest updates the latest
um you know features and so i don't have
this one yet but what this one is going
to be giving us just so you can
be always learning like lifelong leaders
are lifelong learners
and this actually gives you like a
rating of of it
it sees the intro it sees continuous
segments it sees spikes it sees dips
and it's just more it gives you
percentages based on certain areas of
your video
this is the game my friends of
optimizing your content
for audience retention for average view
iteration for top
time on platform for making youtube
happy
because when you make youtube happy
youtube promotes
your content and so other features like
that are coming soon as well
and so make sure you're subscribed uh
here
on youtube or hit the like button if
you're watching this on facebook on the
page
and turn on notifications so that you
can be a part of future coffee with
cannell episodes
and um before we get into questions
today's episode
is brought to you by the weekly think
marketing podcast
definitely make this a part of your
hashtag tuesday ritual
every tuesday we're bringing you a new
episode that you can take on the go
whether you're walking the dog
come on working out come on doing some
chores
going on a walk commuting doing whatever
you're doing
and uh you have it on audio and video
and we're going through a special series
right now
on the think marketing podcast of how to
create a full-time living to make
youtube your job
where i really break down the seven kind
of milestones in my journey from my
successes
my failures my mistakes and so you can
see a link to that most recent episode
it's a three-part series
you can go to part one right now link in
the description below
that's the think marketing podcast on
youtube
so it is a video podcast there or you
can also check it out
on spotify google apple or anywhere you
listen to
podcasts let me know question of the day
how often do you look at youtube
analytics
and what questions do you have about
youtube analytics especially after
watching this video
maybe you're like dang there's a whole
world that's a whole new world
okay we're not gonna have me sing
anybody remember aladdin like does
anybody
of course you remember aladdin i
remember i bought the soundtrack to
aladdin
i had the vhs tape come on abu come on
jafar
you know now we got will smith as the
genie i mean it's
times are a change in you know okay uh
a whole new world out there let me know
your questions about youtube analytics
um what kind of help we could help out
with and we will grab some of those i
got alina
on the think media team helping me today
to um
share out the link and we're gonna bring
some people on the coffee with kennel
show smash
like if you're getting value so far and
let me know what you're drinking i'm
sipping on some ethiopia
beans that i just ground up from uh
brewed the coffee and my aeropress
got these from public us here in las
vegas kind of a niche
single origin um uh
coffee delicious and i'm fired up and
listen
as we get into some questions let me
just encourage you there's about
a little over 70 days left in
2020. if you take out weekends
you take out some holidays chances are
you're gonna probably chill out on
thanksgiving if you're here in the u.s
maybe eat some turkey and some mashed
potatoes what's your favorite dish
for me it's a combo bite do you like the
combo bites
a little bit of mashed potatoes gravy on
there
stuffing a little bit of turkey dark
meat come on dart
team dark meat dude white meat has no
flavor
like it's it's dark meat all the way but
the topping
gravy there's got to be a little
cranberry in that bite as well
and actually i'm going to scoop that
thing onto a little butter buttered roll
and each bite is going to be off put
that like each bite is like a mini
sandwich
and just eat that right off there
there's a sandwich shop in las vegas
called capriati's
that actually kind of makes a
thanksgiving
subway sandwich wow we got deep
uh so let me know
are you a dark meat or a white meat
that's controversial okay uh
type of a person and
what's the point there's around 70 days
left in the year
you can't work every single day some of
you are like i'm grinding that's
probably not super smart because you
gotta rest and tired eyes rarely see a
bright future
but what i want to encourage you just as
we go into questions
and type this in the chat for me is
hashtag
50 day sprint you got about 50 days
if you subtract you know time off
resting
lost days you know just stuff you got to
do of really grinding
you've got about 50 days of really going
for it you've got about 50 days
to really build momentum not just to
finish 2020 strong
but to start 2021 strong
if you want to have momentum going into
january next year you got to start now
you can't wait till your new year's
resolution you can't wait until december
when you're toasting champagne and
thinking now i'm going to start thinking
about my goals it's too late
you got to get your mind right your
grind on your focus fixed
now and i want to encourage you i
realize that 2020 has been hard i
realized
that it's been challenging i realized
that there's been a lot of setbacks
there's been a lot of things
that were in an emotional time that were
in an overwhelming time
that it almost feels like it's
paralyzing
of just what's next what's going to
happen it can sometimes
be hard to even just get out of bed or
even get to work
but you have to shake off apathy you
have to kick complacency in the face
you have to kill distractions
and get hyper focused right now if you
really want to make
progress my friends we are going into
the end
of the year where massive traffic
increases on youtube
where a lot of holiday shopping starts
happening where a lot of
e-commerce starts to spike no matter
what the economy is
there's always people spending money
and their money four to ten x's in
the fourth quarter so for those of you
that are serious
about actually building a real business
about building your influence
about building your youtube channel
about monetizing
about helping people and solving
problems but turning your passion
into a profit while you solve problems
you got to get your grind on now
you got to shake it off man you got to
shake it off taylor swift
come on like loses with the analogy
you got it you got to get focused and i
just want to encourage you for all of
those that are part
of the coffee with kennel community if
you're the first time you've ever
watched this show
nice to meet you my name is sean cannell
and i'm here to help you build your
influence with video
but it's time to not just dabble
on youtube but you gotta start
dominating it's not time
to just sort of ponder about what you're
gonna do next you need to stop pondering
and start posting some freaking videos
i'm here to agitate you
i'm here not just to be a cheerleader
but to be a coach
and to challenge you to say are you
putting out your best work
are you maximizing your week are you
giving in to just scrolling
and looking at what everybody else is
doing and allowing yourself to
be paralyzed by comparison or are you
going to choose
to get focused on your own business
mind your business
focus on your business who cares about
what
other people are doing their business is
none of your
business and your business is none of
their
business get focused ignore the haters
crush complacency and reject
fear i need you to get clear on your
vision write down some goals
and go all in with hashtag 50 day
sprint i know this year is crazy but
literally
if you take action on this even if you
stop watching all of our stuff
you get serious right now i hope this
little pep talk
gives you a spark in your fire to say
man i'm gonna finish this year strong
and if you're a sports fan you've seen
it
we're in the fourth quarter even if the
team is down by 10
down by 20 down by 30 and it looks like
there's
no chance that they can come back and
win the game there has been rallies
that's when they say in basketball when
there's a clutch
player and starts to really rise up when
the pressure is against them
when the clock is ticking down that's
what's happening right now hashtag 50
day sprint and it's time to get clutch
it's time to shut out the crowds
it's time to shut out the noise and it's
time to shut your door
and press record and create some content
and we're here to help so i just wanted
to kind of encourage you
we're in that time right now the time of
recording this and live streaming right
now
hashtag 50 day sprint i know there's
like 71 days left in the year
but you got turkey day right and you got
presents day you got stuff to do
and so uh i hope that encourages
and we're gonna jump into some coffee
with kennel everyone's in the waiting
room like
when's he gonna stop like what is going
on here but we got marie on the show
today marie how's it going where are you
from and uh tell me about your business
and your youtube channel
hi how are you i'm on the show i'm
really good how are you
i'm good thank you i'm from montreal my
husband and i
have a food channel a cooking channel
called food
talks and food talks yeah
so it's a a channel that we started as a
cooking channel in general
but we saw good results when we started
making
pizza videos so now it's more
into pizza making um
a few weeks ago this summer now we're at
245
subs so we don't have too many
subscribers yet
but we used to have really good uh
increase in our watch time something
like 300
percent increase and it
decreased drastically this fall in
september
and mostly in october were at a sad 18
increase in our watch time so we're just
wondering is this something
everyone experiences because of i don't
know the election
this time of the year the fourth quarter
or we're doing something wrong
yeah that's a great question i mean um
you want to always live an attention and
by the way thank you so much for being
on the show
and i'm loving your thumbnails like
taking food good food photography
is a challenge like this most recent one
um man it looks great
and the lighting and the way that those
thumbnails are turning out looks looks
really good
um there's a tension between
awareness of external factors
and making data-driven decisions based
on
seasons and then there's also tension
between just taking
extreme ownership and owning your
results period and it's
it's not black or white it's always
somewhere in the middle
what sometimes i see a mentality which i
don't sense this at all in you as an
entrepreneur but sometimes people in the
youtube community
are like blame everything on the
algorithm
kind of like an extreme way to put it is
it's kind of this victim mentality like
all the
algorithm oh the weather like oh it's
just
and it's just like a constant blame on
everything else but the truth is
that is there's relevancy to that but on
the other side there's always like okay
well if things shift
like you know smooth seas never made
skilled sailors like let's raise up our
skill let's figure out how to navigate
it
and so to your point yes
everything kind of went down uh in
september
it's weird to call it back to school but
that's definitely a relevant
trend um even though back to school
everyone's like not going back to school
they're all virtual you know kids are at
home and so you're like is it really
back to school
but people do kind of like in september
um
you know all right summer's ending at
least that's here kind of in the u.s
right
and it's like sort of back to work back
to school
and there's usually a dip now what am i
referencing well
interestingly enough we had like a lower
month of amazon affiliates and we still
we do some pretty big numbers on amazon
affiliates
but i was like what's happening you know
what's going wrong like why
what what's wrong with us and what we
did was we look back to the year
prior and actually heather and melissa
on the think media team looked up and
they said same thing happened last year
it was just the dip right now and here's
a couple things in terms of revenue now
people in september and even october
maybe start
spending less money on amazon like
amazon affiliates why
because they're waiting for black friday
cyber monday and holiday shopping
they're they're getting their money
ready
so awareness of things like that
are important but now just to give my
own example
not only was their amazon prime day
which i did two different videos about
in response to
trends timing topics i was at whole
foods
and they i saw that i was like amazon
prime days in the middle of october and
so i put it on the calendar i planned
for it
and put out some videos what's the point
i doubled down i did i made
more content i took more actions you
know
we have a pretty big media company now
so it might mean sending more emails
doing more social posts just doing more
things so let's contextualize that to
you
i think it's awareness of saying there's
going to be ups and downs in your in
your channel
there's going to be highs and lows and
some of those are environmental
some days it rains you know some days
it's sunny
but then you always want to be looking
at your analytics and saying what can i
do
to influence this how can i double down
it looks like you're posting two videos
a week
like if you want to make more impact or
even have more chances for a video
taking off or a video going even viral
like you make the right pizza recipe at
the right time with the right thumbnail
that's maybe like a halloween inspired
pizza if that's even a thing you would
do
and right around halloween then it just
kind of takes off and new awareness
comes to your channel
those are the difference makers on
youtube and maybe it's not halloween for
you if that's not
on brand for you but for example amazon
prime day
and me planning strategizing working
getting up early studying
and doing these two live streams led to
almost 60 000 views
when our typical videos lately are
getting like five to ten thousand
so i created like six sex more views on
think media
by actually drafting
nascar reference like indy 500 drafting
behind a trend
behind the timing of a topic so
i hope that's coming across clear it's
not either or it's both and
and it's attention to be managed and let
me also just encourage you and everybody
watching
there's a really good book by darren
hardy called the entrepreneur roller
coaster
and i will link that up in the
description if anybody wants to check it
out audiobook's good
the book's great and and the title kind
of sums up it speaks to a lot of
strategies that we need as entrepreneurs
but it's the fact that being an
entrepreneur is
a roller coaster and starting a youtube
channel is that way as well i am just
hear me i'm not like the little pep talk
i just gave
is not how i get out of bed i wake up i
look at my analytics i see
all red numbers down and i'm like what's
even happening like is
is this whole ship sinking is there any
hope you know i got employees now
is there any way i'm gonna can i even
pay people tomorrow like
high highs and low lows like i'm the
king of the world and like the next day
i'm like you know what
if this whole thing's just i'm just
throwing the towel right now move off
the grid
start sending some home studying
channels and just disappear maybe
i can get you know completely removed
from the system and just start
fishing and living off the land you know
like the
absolute most extreme ex extremes and i
don't even sense that energy from you
but again it's always looking at your
analytics like hey
if it's a rainy day we're going to get
to work if it's a sunny day we're going
to get to work
if it's september we're going to get to
work if it's january we're going to get
to work
and that resolve and that discipline
through every season
is really why your channel will last
over the long haul and will
make it and why others will get stuck
because
of the emotional up and down that
actually
caused them to get sidelined it is
interesting and vidiq could be wrong
here too
because it does say that there's zero
new subscribers which
i doubt but maybe that's true but it's
it's cool to see your consistency with
the nine uploads in the last month
and i want to encourage you while i look
at this
it does say your views are up so even if
we talk about emotionally
like based on this data which i'm
looking at vidiq pulling it from
publicly
from september 18th to october 18th
you're 35
better than the month before that so
that's also
an interesting thing is to really make
sure you know there's two different
mindsets i know you were talking about
like some breakout videos and some
things and now it's
but i'm also like if you're growing like
that like imagine if apple grew by 35
they might with the new iphone 12.
imagine if apple grew by 35
that'd go from like 1 trillion market
cap to 1.3 trillion
i mean you think 35 that's a remarkable
number
so that's also why making data-driven
decisions um
is is huge and you're still early in the
journey so i hope this is encouraging
but let me know does that make sense and
do you have any kind of follow-up
questions about that
well thank you so much i just wanted to
say we have a thanks
thanksgiving pizza coming up smart
smart thanksgiving are you gonna do some
other holiday pizzas
uh we haven't planned it yet but i guess
now we have to so thank you so much for
your tips
you're very welcome your baby boy thank
you so much
and uh thanks for uh coming on the
coffee with kennel
thank you bye bye bye
data-driven decisions man when you look
at your numbers
you can at least make better decisions
sometimes though
are you like me where you you open up
your youtube channel and like the
numbers are all red
one of the things we talk about in our
video ranking academy is we just say go
for green
like if it's always green that means
it's always growing at least you're
making forward progress
but you might be like but sean it's not
it's not green dog it's
it's red man it's been it's been a dark
you know 2020.
and i get it there's ups there's downs
key is
do not quit right all right we got uh
zach in the house today zach how's it
going welcome to the
panel show uh tell me about your
business your channel and uh what you're
up to
first of all big fan man thanks for
having me on the channel
i am just uh i work full-time
at my church right now and i do youtube
on the side
uh after a long time uh
media director cool where's the church
it's in ventura california yesterday
okay yeah yeah that dude i i mean i grew
up
with jude fuquay and judah smith at
youth pastor
luncheons at city church
2003 and four i would drive from my
small town
with jeff moores and david luster our
co-leading
youth pastors of our 20-kid
youth ministry and uh major influence
man going down and being a part of
obviously now church home but
uh but city church with wendell smith at
the time anyways so
so deep roots as tony on the think media
team would say deep cuts
but anyways back to you just a little
history there
yeah so i uh recently had just taken on
this position full-time you know just
with the shift of media
and i've been doing youtube pretty much
since uh march
when i was working on another job it's
uh just my own personal it's
zach sopak z-a-c-s-o-p-a-k
and uh just out of the passion of uh
learning so much from youtube over the
years with
photo video editing all that stuff
and it's just like i want to give back
to people and really
i would love to make that my full-time
job and then be able to take what i do
for my church and do that
as a sort of a means of just my service
there
so one of one of my questions i had i
know you're looking at um
some of my stuff there like one of my
biggest videos was a webcam video
and that was closer to the beginning of
covid of course like capture cards were
out of stock and different things like
that and that's
been my best video so far and
i'm trying now to i guess replicate
success
that i had with that video with other
ones because i don't want to just be
like the webcam guy i want to be able to
add value to people who want to build up
their
uh their skill set in their photo and
video
work yeah yeah i mean it's a it's a good
question
um and what that presents is atten
attention that we all face um eventually
in the life
of every youtube creator will come
your best video your breakout video and
whether your breakout video gets 500
views when normally you get 50
or whether it gets 500 000 when normally
you get 5 000
you make enough videos over enough
length of time
during enough seasons i mean that speaks
and props to you for like taking action
creating content
during the lockdown i mean you think
about this is that's a negative thing
that happened
a you know a tragedy a hard season
you jumped in served and help people and
solve problems
and that is one of the videos that's led
to probably the most awareness that
you've had so far on youtube just to put
into perspective
to always be creating and to encourage
our community always be creating
always turn lemons into lemonade and
think about how you can solve problems
entrepreneurs solve problems but back to
zack
eventually you have a breakout video and
a lot of times let me know community
in the comments what is your top and
most viewed video
a lot of times it can be
frustrating because sometimes your top
viewed video
almost like what people feel like is it
brands them
or puts them in a particular direction
or it starts that that they
maybe didn't want to go in and uh some
people
their top viewed video this is this can
actually be a problem
is unrelated to the content they're
creating now so the
the video that is bringing the most
growth and most awareness of most
subscribers
could actually be people are clicking
subscribe but then your new content is
not something they want to see because
it's unrelated to the video that's
generating the most viewership
so let me know in the comments what your
top viewed video is in your case i don't
think it's a problem
i think it's on brand to kind of the
overall value proposition
which seems to be you know similar to
think media uh
helping people get great results on zoom
cameras camera bags and then obviously
covering niche things and
and uh and and um and there's so many
people in the world and just serving and
helping people
so there's maybe two quick tips that i
would give you
i think one is um
you want to think deeply i'll give you
three tips
number one you do want to think deeply
about where this is that
you where you want it to ultimately go
because
what can happen when we are pursuing
growth which is not a bad thing to
pursue but when we're pursuing growth
is once youtube starts to give us
signals or instagram
or tick tock we go oh that's what the
robot's like
well let me dance more for the robots
like let me please the robots more
which may or may not be aligned
with our highest goal highest vision
highest purpose
because what good is it to climb the
mountain only to realize you climbed the
wrong mountain
not that it's a horrible thing but
eventually you're like i don't want to
be the webcam guy so you already gave me
clarity
that you don't want to be the webcam guy
okay so
additionally though a term
that i think you could apply for all
your videos really starting moving
forward is bridge marketing
to the degree that you are clear in your
videos about what it is you stand for
and what people are subscribing for
you may have these splinter off videos
that cover things that are
slightly removed from the core promise
of your channel
but bridge marketing is always offering
people a bridge like towards the end of
the video if people even make it there
right barely any people
but like that you know at minute five or
minute ten
really like so i hope you enjoyed this
you know sony camera webcam video
and this is where maturity as leaders
and content creators comes
to where we should actually encourage
people not to subscribe and here's what
i mean like that's
because the worst thing that you
actually can have happen to the youtube
algorithm is have everyone in the world
subscribe
because if people subscribe that aren't
going to consume your future content
it's actually going to drive your click
through rate down they are actually
going to signal to youtube that they're
just not interested in what you're
creating
so you want to kind of polarize your
subscribers it's you don't want
everybody to
subscribe to your channel you want the
right people to subscribe to your
channel by offering a bridge
so bridge marketing is like so look you
know mainly what i'm passionate about
is filmmaking and cinematic video so if
when it comes to color grading
and cameras and lighting it's kind of
the core thing we talk about we also
talk about kind of fun stuff like this
on the channel but
that's sort of the main thing so if
you're into that kind of stuff then hit
subscribe
and i'll see in the next video now again
you may or may not
share so many words because we could get
into all kinds of conversations about if
you're saying that at minute 10 they're
already gone because they know you're
landing the plane
but if you get the intent it's clarity
about
why are people subscribing to the
channel and offering a bridge
and in some cases my philosophy on
youtube is youtube's kind of a very
wide uh you know
super wide reaching honestly what i'm
describing is just lessons i've learned
at think media
where we have all kinds of videos that
are kind of not even one-off
but like we don't only make best camera
for youtube videos
yet those are the most viewed videos so
maybe people don't care about the other
stuff we're saying
but here's the key we do things like
build email lists we do things like
when someone signs up for an email list
about something specific
if they sign up to watch our free
youtube master class
they have said i want to learn youtube
like so
dead specific so now you're if you will
uh categorizing or in our in a
in a crm or like a planning center or
like a fellowship one or whatever like a
church software
you're kind of like saying these are the
women's ministry these are the men
like you're saying these are people that
are into youtube we have a think gear
guide
and so those are people okay they're
into gear they might not be into youtube
tips
think media is kind of both but like if
they sign up for the gear guide then
they for sure
want to be followed up with with on tech
so we i now have built an email list
along with the team
of segments that's what i'm looking for
segmented audiences that you can
communicate with so let's land the plane
and i'll hit any follow-up questions so
the first one
is uh is bridge marketing
i think uh secondly you know thinking
about what is the big vision
like what is it you want to build what
does winning look like for you where
does it
that you want it to go and the third tip
is also just don't overthink it
like if only if even to connor dick
myself is like
who cares you know i don't know like
making like
like maybe some people will think you're
the webcam guy who cares like
they're they're just doing drive-bys
anyways like you got 19 000 views
double down on the winners do more of
what's working
you know will this be my brand forever
will i be doomed to be the webcam
livestream guy
in some people's eyes i'm sure like i
probably am the
fill in the blank guy about a thousand
different
definitions to a thousand different
people
whatever like the people who vibe with
you and go deeper with you
are gonna click on your instagram and
follow you on instagram and get to know
you more
or click subscribe because they actually
resonate with your personality
so i hope that all of this kind of
thinking
adds some point of view and perspective
but i think there's a point of don't
overthink it i think
that's like it's like don't quote
unquote sell your soul
to the robots to just do what's going to
please the algorithm and the tension is
sell your soul to the robots and you
know what i mean like literally
i mean why because like it's not it's
it's if it's
like if it's the videos that are getting
views listen that gives you the chance
to do the bridge marketing it gives you
the chance to basically
if you will placate for views likes and
i don't think that's the case because
you're talking about how to use like if
you're talking about cam links or
streaming and streaming on sony's and
getting good
you obviously have all your look on your
videos and all that stuff really dialed
so then it's just a bridge and
invitation into your world and people
get to know you and they get to
learn your mission learn your purpose
learn who you are
see what you're about so reaching super
wide and only having two percent
of people of a video that reaches a
million people
and 98 are just like i just wanted the
webcam thing
is zach they don't even know who zack is
they will watch your video
like this happens to me a lot now as i
think media's kind of got big people
come up they don't know my name
they don't know probably much about me
but they they look at me and they're
like
are you i think i think
i think you're the guy that helped me
buy my camera
like they don't follow me anywhere like
you know what i mean like it's just it
was a
total drive-by and there's so many
different degrees
and you don't want to get overly
romantic about what you even think is
happening with your viewers
out of the 19 000 people that watch that
video
18 900 were like oh sick you solved the
problem i was searching for
i'm out and 100 were like oh zack's kind
of cool and that's how you it even maps
to the fact i mean you're on your way to
600 subscribers
that's how you actually build your a
thousand true fans you're a thousand
super fans and then beyond is just by i
do
think paying attention to the wider
topics
making the content but then you know
funneling down and using some of these
other strategies what do you think about
that and let me know if you have any
follow-up questions
uh no man that is that's exactly the
type of stuff i needed to hear
yeah i think uh just because it is the
early stages i just uh
i guess i had that fear of maybe i'm
just pigeonholing myself
like early on but i love what you said
about the bridge marketing and
i i think that's that's probably my my
angle
where i need to start going with it yeah
i love it and uh
man i appreciate you and i appreciate
you coming on don't worry about
pigeonholing yourself
again you might you may you've probably
by this time a lot of people in our
community have heard about gary
vaynerchuk
who influenced my life because i read
crush it back when it came out in 2009
why now is the time to cash in on your
passion when my wife was sick and in the
hospital and
and um it was a spark to
what i'm doing today but at the time he
was
he had a wine show where he was
reviewing wine
five days a week for his wine library tv
shop in new york city or new jersey and
and and now nobody even knows that now
people know him as the business coach or
the motivation guy
or the hustle guy or the social media
guy and so
he created over a thousand episodes
reviewing wine you wanna talk about
being pigeonholed wrote a book
on wine you're like dude that's all
you'll ever be known for
like you know what i mean like you
you're in the hole and it's
unrecoverable and you cannot climb out
it's not true
like the way you start steering in a
different direction with your brand
is you just start creating content in a
different direction you just start
planting your flag new titles new videos
and having the
willingness the clarity the resolve
to be okay if the numbers go down
because then that's like what it really
comes down to
is people can get so caught up and we're
all guilty of this and just kind of the
vanity metrics
even the haters like someone on think
media like we'll make a video that's
meaningful and deep
and someone will be like oh you got so
many subscribers why are the views so
low and you're like it's not all about
just reach it's also about depth and you
don't understand the iceberg
underneath think media bro you know like
me responding like 12 year old leader so
like there's there is uh it's kind of
that iceberg of knowing that clarity of
where's this all going
what's the bigger picture and so i'm
excited to see your journey man i'm
pumped that she came on the show and
that we uh got connected
man thanks so much i i really appreciate
it enjoy all the content love all that
you guys do
awesome zack appreciate you thanks for
coming on peace
yes bridge marketing hey hashtag bridge
marketing
50 day sprint my friends we have a
couple more people coming on but my
question
for you is what are you committed to
making happen
in the next by 2021
in the next 50 days of actual work days
days you can hustle even if it's at
night in the morning
before your one month old gets up
why you're one month old is in your arm
last night and you're
kind of like trying to use one hand but
he gets mad because you took it off the
pacifier so like you could barely
you get about like one keystroke typed
come on parents
each time and then you're like you put
the thing in the deal and then you're
like type type and he starts
like there's he's so aware okay what are
you committed to making happen
in the next 50 days sprint what's the
goal type it out
sean i don't want to type i'm just
listening pull the car over
be safe don't text and drive or comment
and drive
um and and respond why it's because when
if it's not written it's not real
put it out into the world what you're
committed to making
happen um beards and banjos wants to hit
a thousand subs
uh after two and a half years respect
on that hustle by the end of the year i
believe you could do it especially if
you get super focused in the next 50
days francis
wants to hustle to 34 videos making him
messy i appreciate it francis
thanks for posting that marcus i'm
committed to getting my first affiliate
income let's go
um what are you committed to making
happen in the next
50 days nona is on the way to 20 000
subs let's go
um what are you committed to making
happen commitment
is the foundation of great
accomplishments determination
focus and if i could offer one
piece of hard-won advice that i'm the
most guilty of
i'm with you in the challenge of i think
the most insidious
destructive
saboteur of your success
this year there's maybe a lot of things
you think could fit in the category of
what i'm about to say but i'm gonna say
it
is distractions is distractions i think
your number one public enemy number one
is distractions
scrolling interruptions
like taking your focus off the goal
working on the wrong
project getting distracted i don't know
if you got distracted oh there's an
ad those jeans are on sale oh you got
distracted oh peter mckinnon just posted
a new video think media just posted a
new video
oh you get distracted oh you know what
oh there's a new episode
of the season finale of third day on hbo
mask max
or raise with wolves you get distracted
come on somebody you
you get distracted if you want to crush
it over the next 50 days you got to get
focused and you have to kill
distractions
couple book recommendations deep work by
cal newport
most people 99 of people in modern
culture are doing
shallow work you're sending tweets but
you're not creating videos
you're doing reels which are great by
the way but you're not creating youtube
videos that will rank and bring you
traffic for weeks months and years to
come because of the power of the youtube
algorithm
cool tick tock bro went viral i don't
know what that means
no disrespect but i don't know i mean
what's it going to do for you
but what's a strategic well thought out
well-designed
massive value-adding video that actually
builds your business on youtube that'll
get views for weeks months and years to
come and actually attract
an audience that maps to your end goal
gotta get focused you got to kill the
distractions
i'm not preaching at you i'm preaching
at me we got to kill distractions
let's finish this year strong get super
hyper focused on our goals and then shut
out everything else
you know what distractions could also be
too many goals we narrowed down to three
big goals in think media for the last
three months
three big goals that we rallied the
whole 12 of us around
and we i and and that seems like oh
sean's not very many goals i got like 22
goals
good luck with that focus every day i
wake up there's 100 things i want to do
oh should i work on this
oh there's this thing i kind of want to
do over here or i kind of want to do
some like
product review thing and i think about
things is that connected to my main goal
is that connected to my clear purpose is
that connected
to that target you got to get super
laser focused right now
50 days sprint and
kill distractions
oh man you gotta interrupt your
interruptions
um okay helen this week i've been
setting up my youtube channel my goal is
to have my niche 60
clarified hyper growth clarity sheet
number one i love that clear
and i love how detailed helen you what
you wrote down was
the greater detail uh you put your goals
and your uh your targets in
the better um
how will you know when you get there if
you don't know where you're going
what is winning look like exactly
define that okay uh tina just pulled
over
tina fist bump um i'm gonna edit my
videos and finally start my channel
thank you for being safe to reply to the
comment that's some serious dedication
on the coffee with kennel show
and so i appreciate you there um and if
you want to check out in the comments
alina
linked up deep work it's a deep book but
cal newport
is actually not active on social media i
got some other people coming on the show
thank you for your patience
let me hit this we just talked and i got
people helping me on social media and we
just talked we're like man
in fact it was melissa and heather who
do the think marketing q a
right uh here on the think marketing
channel depending on where you're
watching this
and melissa and heather were like uh
sean it'd be really great if you really
started doing reels and i was like
listen i was in like that saucy mode
like no sleep i was like i agree
and i've done three this is instagram
reels and i was like
but with a new son one month in
and our three big company goals and
five videos a week over on think media
and two videos a week on think marketing
melissa
i've got enough going on right now if i
have some time
and then i said with the inner circle
training that i'm doing this thursday
and then with the vid iq brand deal
training that i got to do next week
and then with the camera confidence
final module that i'm recording next
week
and then with the session i have to
prepare to speak at 100x conference
and then with the session that i have to
prepare speak at eileen wilder's
high ticket conference virtual event and
then
with the new master class and and uh
youtube class that we are recording by
my deadline in november
and the two bat shoot days that we are
doing of the think marketing podcast
in november if i'm gonna hit all those
dates i better not be doing freaking
reels today
if i wake up today and i'm like oh look
reels are cool they're going viral
respect bro
cool reels i love them but if that's not
your main purpose you got to get on
purpose
you got to shut out distractions and
maybe some of the other social media
sites
are not what you have bandwidth for
right now maybe it's just about getting
that
one youtube video done that better
youtube video done and i was like i
would rather do a few things well
than be a jack of all trades but a
master of none
focus kill distractions hashtag 50 day
sprint let me know if you're getting
value smash like if you're getting value
kill distractions
i do not have grandparents nearby that's
why i'm upset
uh i'm just kidding i don't actually but
you know thank god for
uh a my wife sonia heather taurus
isaiah taurus the godparents uh you know
jordan on the think media team uh the el
tocoris
our church family we do have um a
community
and my mom came up for about a week i
appreciate the question
but we're trying to figure this out as
new parents i'm
so on edge nobody else wants to come on
the show cause they're about to get
snapped out by a sleepless
dad okay kill distractions hashtag
50 day sprint we got michelle from
athlete remedy on the coffee with kennel
show today michelle
where are you from and uh what's your
business and youtube channel
hey sean what's going on um i am
coming at you from miami florida um
my channel is athlete remedy and
i am an athletic trainer i focus on
rehab recovery
sports injuries and i actually
uh joined just joined inner circle um
after growth video live and shout out to
you and the team for making an
incredible
virtual event um and so
i i think i joined youtube like i don't
know years ago and i
as you'll see i just threw stuff at the
wall
for a while and saw it stick what would
stick i didn't really have a plan i i
just
you know and i kind of forgot about it
um and getting more into like the think
media world and
learning etc um and definitely after the
conference and now joining inner circle
i i will say i've gotten a lot more
clarity um
because i feel like i was chasing
like so many things so i gotta grow
instagram and then i gotta go do this
and i have to like go on tick tock and i
have
you know i got to grow my email you know
and i and but i was like really getting
nowhere
so um so my question
um is based on
kind of the the strategy of of
videos now coming and as i'm preparing
um i'm like making a plan and i'm doing
my 50-day sprint
um if you look on my channel similar to
um
i think zach who was just on i
the one video that i randomly threw on
there which i think i did like a
facebook live randomly one time
has like i don't even know how many
views 19
like six seventeen thousand how to treat
a jam sprained finger
like what so i'm kind of like mind blown
because first of all i didn't do it on
purpose
and i i did that like i think a year ago
and
so i to be honest because i was i was
kind of studying
and getting organized for now for the
rest of the of
of the year and into next year i
didn't even realize that this video was
doing
was still getting views until i got a
message through instagram from somebody
that watched it and was asking me a
follow-up question because i guess i i
put on there hey you know you can
comment here
or you know shoot me a dm and so i go
back and i look and i'm like whoa
and i realized so now of course i i've
got
two follow-up like videos that i want to
do for that um
i went ahead and spent some time and
made just like a freebie
um to put on there figured it has a lot
of views
it's continuing to get views i can do a
quick
pdf guide that really didn't take me a
long time
just to have there um and you know and
kind of move on
right to kind of have a call to action
because there's nothing on there
so with all that said uh
i had recorded a video on a completely
different topic
about like ankle sprains that i had
edited it took
you know as i'm learning i've never even
done this before but
it took me however long it took me and i
had this plan like okay this is gonna be
like a three you know
thinking about playlists and whatnot and
continuity
uh i kind of halted because now i'm like
well wait does it make sense to do that
and i should have a call to action
i also don't want to get caught in well
now i'm making all these different
free you know freemiums or download you
know
am i is that a bad strategy at the end
of the day
um i know i know
it made sense whole bridge marketing
that you were just talking about uh
it clicked for me because i don't see it
as random like they are related you know
whoever is interested in more and sort
of the umbrella of it will come
and that can always be a way to get them
into my world for the bigger thing
so you know does it matter
if i post this ankle video
um before this other one should i
you know should am i overthinking it
here should i just think about being
consistent and like that one's ready
just get it on and move to the next etc
um
so hopefully all that kind of gives you
a little bit of insight to kind of where
i'm at
yeah i love it and so grateful you're
part of inner circle and um
and let's dive in so first and foremost
what's awesome is obviously you have
pillar number one claimed and mastered
your topic
this is your expertise it's what you
have results on
and even to the tune of you know 17 000
views on this
uh it's helping people it's serving
people um i also
just to celebrate the power of youtube
that your past library brought in 2829
views even though you haven't uploaded
in five months right and you still grew
16 subscribers
even though you haven't uploaded so as
you add more this is why
i love youtube the most and again no
disrespect against
tick tock or instagram or reels but i'll
tell you this
no tick tocks are getting you views and
no instagram posts are going to get you
subscribers and views five months
later after they die out and so as you
build up a base of videos that's why we
love youtube the most
that's why it's the best place to
establish your brand and your business
and i know you know that
um the first thing i would say is i do
think
i think in general you are overthinking
uh we can get in it's it's
good you are thinking about things but
the promise of your channel is clear
and you you want to just post videos
what videos should you post next
it doesn't matter i mean post one a week
um
how good should the videos be you've
probably built up in your mind that now
they need to
you know now that you're part of inner
circle and like really studying think
media
that they need to be at this next level
no they don't like your
most viewed video was a facebook live so
you really just want to take
massive imperfect action and just keep
putting out smart topics um
at a done is perfect you know done is
better than perfect level
and and keep that momentum going because
that's what's going to lead to your
subscriber base
what's going to lead to growth on the
channel and what's going to get you that
momentum and that traffic
leading into whatever email list you
want to build whatever
course you want to potentially build
later
the most important thing we need to talk
about though is the absolute big picture
let me point out some vulnerabilities
you know
utility channels like yours is the same
um challenge that think media falls into
when you have a utility channel you're
usually not getting
a subscriber that cares maybe more than
about the one thing they came for
if it's a search-based video like the
video that's doing really well for you
somebody's like i've got a drink
jammed sprained finger from sports
youtube how do i treat it oh my goodness
michelle's video helped me thanks
michelle i don't even know your name's
michelle even though you said it i'm
gone
and the utility solved their problem and
then they move on in life
what is the point of that individual um
once they have that problem solved do
they need more help
now you mentioned bridge marks marketing
which is huge because in every
future piece of content you create you
want to invite people
into something yeah and your clarity on
that something
would be the you know the audience you
want to build the vision you want to
build
and that something needs to be
compelling it needs to be you know
polarizing because you can't
reach everybody for example if i talk
about best camera for youtube
somebody might go i don't care about
youtube tips in fact
i don't even know if i want to start a
youtube channel i just wanted your
camera reviews
great now think about this let's just
use that as a case study
someone searches m50 or sony a6400
they might not care about youtube
strategy they might not care about
youtube tips
they don't care about my book youtube
secrets necessarily they just
are trying to decide which camera to buy
they watch the video
and they go wow this was very
informative omar and sean broke that
down
they might click a link in the
description powerful
because it's a search-based video about
cameras you have a search-based video
about epson salt bath with the affiliate
link in the description great job
it should be in the top three lines of
text to get more clicks get a little
affiliate money going just a tip because
it's kind of buried down a little bit
yes and so uh
they watch the video on cameras
potentially
you know pick up a camera which is the
original way i was able to reach
full-time
freedom freedom i don't recommend that
necessarily to everybody because it
could take a while to get like amazon to
full-time
but in tech with my knowledge of ranking
that's what i did right
and so so even if it's utility-based
it still practically led to
reaching a vision vision of going full
time being able to
you know go all in but bridge marketing
is and hey by the way if you
want to not just learn about which
cameras are best for creating content
but learn the strategies and tips
i have a freemium
if they say well i'm interested in that
they raise their hand they have now
joined you in the journey towards
a goal that is ultimately where i would
think
you would be taking people that could
lead to building your
business yeah let me just give you one
idea and we can discuss it
but now you get into the idea of okay is
someone going to let's say you want to
create an online course which is what we
really recommend everybody watching
eventually do with with the e-learning
industry
exploding especially over the next five
years it is the wave
it is i think the best way to make money
from home
highly leveraged we have we cover that
in other videos
but are there a lot of people who want
to buy a sports recovery online course
maybe maybe not but are there people who
may be
i like to go to udemy not my favorite
place to host a course i see you already
have kajabi but
uh but it's a good place to do some
research and i'm gonna type in physical
therapy to just kind of get a vibe
on on what people are maybe doing
with physical therapy now this
particular course
you know it only has 48 students which
which this is good data because that's
not a ton so i think okay
now it's only two and a half hours
and this comes into the idea of if you
will
being b to b or b to c b
you know yeah yes you're the business
the c is the consumer
the consumer is the person who maybe
would buy an online course on physical
therapy
or or like recovery they might not do
that and they might buy a fitness course
beachbody is like b to c beachbody is
the business
c is the person watching my friend
chalene johnson on piyo
they're the consumer and and they want
to do home workouts well that's a huge
market
but then it's kind of like okay but b2b
would be
other people who maybe want to do what
you do is a theory
like or is an option and then you
research
so again if we add this up it's it's not
a ton but it would be a trickle of
income if
if you had videos that it also and said
and hey
if you're interested in like learning
techniques and learning and learning how
to make a career in physical therapy
um grab my free guide you know that
might lead your online course or maybe
it goes direct to a 34
course because it's a little bit lower
ticket and 1 679
comes in um you know so far for this
course
this and this is just kind of doing some
research do you see what i'm talking
about here what's your thoughts
yeah i i i totally uh have done a little
bit of research and just to gain
just you know information or insight
into yeah what is out there
um my main because of my my background
um you know my in my day job and really
my career
thus far i've worked uh a lot with with
high school athletes
and so i have and collegiate um
and so that's really kind of the the you
know
the basis of really like my following um
i also like i would say on instagram
which is probably probably my biggest
following right now like
uh around 3000 and i also have
their parents on facebook um
which i have a group there and so i've
just spent some time just sort of
listening and getting a feel for
you know what is it that they would
potentially be interested in buying or
what questions are they continually
asking me
so that then i can i can create
something
um and so beyond beyond uh just a
standalone course
um i mean aside from maybe a like a
mini course or a baby course that you
guys talk about you know i
i envision going into some sort of a
membership a bigger like the big
ticket not big ticket as in price
necessarily but
the big kind of the core um
of having a resource uh you know as an
athlete just because
those those particular people are
you know underserved in the way that you
know this information kind of goes
if that makes sense um 100
and let me give you an example so this
comes back to
um what we say at the foundation and
you're at a great place even with your
channel it's where your channel pivots
and steers now
of picking a proven and a profitable
niche really getting clear
on actually really the whole destiny
like the whole journey
yeah and there's a guy who uh we've
connected a little bit i'd say we're
kind of acquaintance friends adam
linkburger
uh also uh teaches youtube because he's
helped
grow a channel uh of basketball tips
grew a massive massive channel of people
that want to increase their jump and
stuff
and um now i love basketballtraining.com
and so it starts out with an uh an
opt-in
as russell brunson would say you could
funnel hack this and kind of get an idea
for what they're doing but i think it's
clarity on saying okay
welcome to the future of basketball
training super
clear one specific sport even we're not
just the biggest we're the best
you won't believe this it's an elite
training portal
you know get on the wait list it looks
like they're updating things you know
uh you get the best trainers in the
world elite high school college and nba
players
so you know this is kind of what they're
doing but it's been all in basketball
it's been like specific results like
this online course
and they've done millions now in sales
um
from the youtube channel i believe it's
the maybe even i love basketball youtube
channel
so anyways that's the kind of
clarity it's two million subscriber
youtube channel where you
you look and you think okay um you know
five
vertical jump killers so let's check
this out
you know they're doing their thing
they're creating content and they've
been building this up for years
okay and then we get this three inches
and three minutes guide
add three inches to your vertical jump
in three minutes or less
such good marketing right because it's
you start going back to where
even if someone's like growing their
physical therapy career i don't actually
think that would
i don't think that's dialed in yet like
it's probably not i was like oh wow an
online course on like how to become
but like this is a high passion high
desire
um man i want to jump higher i want to
be able to dunk
i want to be able to win that dunk
contest whatever you know i want
and it's a very specific one problem one
pain point
you get the opt-in and the whole thing
happens and and then eventually
with the course built and everything
else built let's see
there's another one free professional
workout that helps you add six to ten
points to your game
very specific result of what that'll
help you do so anyways i think
now definitely you've got some work to
do as you're already working
but in terms of going through inner
circle
dialing in your content i wouldn't
hesitate though to still post
videos because that's also just part of
just as you would recommend
just like the discipline use it or lose
it man like you you don't
don't wait oh i'm not really gonna like
start the seasons for six months so let
me just take six months off no you got
it yeah
you gotta have the discipline it gives
you kind of the insights it gives you
the momentum
and you already have enough clarity to
start steering like you're already on
brand i think for what your channel is
and you're experimenting
so if you just start dialing it in but i
would funnel hack
some of what i love basketball is doing
because when you really zero in on okay
what's the big idea what's the right
audience what's eventually the right
offer
what's this all going to lead to and
then you can be a very dynamic brand
like in the terms of think media
we put out a video that someone's like
yeah i don't care about your
your free youtube class i don't want it
which eventually you know talks about
video ranking academy of course
i just want the camera advice so so you
might eventually
it's through the holidays like five best
recovery tools
for athletes or maybe just five you know
and it's exercise bands and
whatever yeah and so there's like there
becomes
multiple different things you could do
that stay on brand that maybe bring in
income you could kind of dabble in
affiliate marketing
you can have a brand where people follow
you for particular reason and you
collaborate with i love basketball
and it's a jv like a million
opportunities happen as you build your
base and your
opportunity think media legitimately has
over like 10 six-figure income streams
like we've done
just to say that like whether eventually
it's book sales
or audiobook or online courses or
affiliate marketing
yeah partnering with other people to
promote their programs
or events and obviously that's years
down the road in a team and it depends
on your ambition
but that's what i want to call you back
to the center of kind of getting as
clear as possible
and posting content because it's that
momentum of me as a solo creator
committing to get that video up a week
and if i was super busy with my job
it was a video a month it was four
during the summer and it was eight
during the holidays because i was like
black friday cyber monday let's go
and i would do my whole gift idea series
yeah so coming back to the baseline
of just like you would tell me to keep
doing my push-ups and my reverse lunges
to keep my ligaments
you know i don't know uh i'm telling you
yeah
record yeah it's it's it's interesting
that you even just an example with
basketball because i actually was
thinking about
is it okay if i if i for a while at
least kind of focus on basketball like
in in relating the recovery stuff
because i i do have a lot of experience
with it i do have a big following that
that that plays basketball i have like
you know
clout like i've got success within that
sport and so i was
better is it okay it's better
yeah like the the famous saying the
riches
are in the niches and so
sports recovery in general like cool but
like the mentality of the older golfer
who's like
well that i subscribed but like i'm not
getting
all these you know there's a couple
basketball videos or some golf stuff
it's for different age
you know what i'm saying like the more
you pitch down to understand that person
the better
it's it's also you're already niched
like
athlete remedy people in the audience be
like oh it's clear like it's
but like it's even better to be more
niched down
to the point by the way millions in
sales millions of dollars in sales from
the i love basketball brand
for being more niched not the not the
you know help you add six to ten points
to your game
and more soccer goals and
40 yards to your drive all of a sudden
you like if you try and reach everybody
you end up reaching nobody even in terms
of like athletic performance i mean it
kind of makes sense
but that then it really becomes and
totally
just to encourage you and everybody
watching too it's interesting
because of even inner circle and because
we're on so many platforms and
and heather just sent me like i don't
know we got a quarter million views on
facebook
video views and those can be
distractions
why so in third quarter i said man
youtube
like no it's youtube like i gotta go
back to youtube and not that i ever left
but i was like i didn't write facebook
secrets i didn't write instagram secrets
i didn't write tick-tock secrets i
didn't write
real you know instagram reels like
i've been but i've been talking about
this so long it's easy to get into other
things
i want to go deeper and deeper and
deeper
and i like every entrepreneur watching
right it's like constant squirrels and
whatever man
if you could keep the blinders on and
that maybe i think basketball really
resonates in this talk
but it's also being willing to
experiment i mean you could do a season
of basketball like see how it goes like
right you know but uh there's something
so powerful
you know social media secrets probably a
good book that's a lot of different
directions
like it's really nice to be known for
the one thing
and to go deep on the one thing but as
long as i've done this now i
i'm so dang tempted to just go in
a million other directions right now and
so i'm hoping to pass along to you and
everybody
no keep doubling down like keep being
even more clever i've seen too many
people pivot away
from kind of that core genius and
there's sure a time to do that earlier
in the call right
gary vaynerchuk from wine to business
like by the way that was about like a 10
years
and 10 years thing and i'm you know i
don't know five years since think media
really got serious whatever
point being man niches and this has
become the number one bestselling
youtube strategy book in the world very
focused
one platform and we're here today
talking about new updates still talking
about the same thing still talking about
the book
some people are like you repeat yourself
i'm like yeah that's why you win
is actually if you are if you stay on
message and you actually keep saying
a lot of the same things in new ways
instead of constantly trying to say
different things
you can never build momentum in any one
direction so anyways
kind of a rant but i would hate resonate
with you i love it i it totally that
that definitely kind of answered a
question and brought even more clarity
uh into more narrow focus into what the
clarity i was already getting so thank
you for that
and um i will say lastly uh uh
you talked about like affiliate
marketing i know you guys talk about uh
you know what's the quickest path to
revenue and
i i i happen to catch your
your video or your live stream about
prime day
like late late meaning like i i didn't i
just
couldn't like do a video however um
i i had like an old you know amazon
affiliate account i just
whatever i got at some point anyway just
from me recommending within facebook
groups
that you know people are asking and
knowing about hey it's prime day well
let me just drop a link but be helpful
uh i just checked and i was like there's
like 25
commission i was like no way i'm like oh
and so i i know like in your story about
like the two dollars or whatever i'm
like man this feels so
awesome like i didn't even that wasn't
even like that much effort like wow
so now i'm thinking i've got ideas for
the holiday
so black friday just in general on
christmas etc
to finish out for video ideas and i
actually
i have like a kit.co up
because i i wanted to to see how many
you know views i could get on different
things to gauge kind of what was worth
you know doing videos on uh relating it
to the topic
um and so so along with that is there a
strategy as far as when to post
um so let's say for black friday let's
say that kind of week um
you know should you post you know that
right when black friday begins you know
uh that week before you know what's kind
of the
as far as you know more a little bit
more tactical with that as far as timing
um if if you could touch upon that
that'd be
that'd be yeah i think uh i've got i've
got i've been so i've been doing between
that i've been doing like verse like
this versus this research on like for
example massage guns or like
this yeah i was actually about to bring
those up yeah huge topic and so i've got
a couple different brands i'm going to
do this versus uh
then relating it into kind of how to use
it you know
i want to not just do like a product
review i want to also integrate
hey like something practical a practical
use so that it
ties into i'm gonna add that into like a
guide
as well like i have all that like so i
just wanna know like okay when i'm
ready to to post when
you know when does it make sense to kind
of do that when when sort of that starts
yeah so you're better so for black
friday it can be hard because you may
not know what the deals are
and you you try to post as soon as you
can like for me
i went live on prime day the night
before
with some information but prime day
didn't start until the next day so then
i went
live again in the morning and i kind of
used the one live to
sort of daisy chain and sort of like
build momentum into the whole prime day
because
again it wasn't until midnight that that
amazon revealed all the deals
so the other thing you can look at is
google trends though so what i did was i
typed in black friday
uh i typed in you could go past five
years and you can select youtube search
so it's obviously going to kind of be
the same time but what we call these is
tent poles
and so these are the tent poles of when
search increases
and you can see that it really starts to
spike let's go back to uh uh
last 12 months that it really starts to
spike
around november 17th uh and then
obviously on black friday itself around
the 24th
and then it even kind of drops off and
maybe people still want to know what
products you talked about or whatever
so you want to ride the up
and then potentially uh it you know not
be on the down
or definitely not too late or even too
early
so you kind of want to hit potentially
november 17th if you knew what the black
friday deals
potentially were to your point it's so
funny you were talking about massage
guns
because you know they're everywhere i'm
doing
exactly and i'm um you know
well off financially because of our
business and whatnot but i spent
freaking six hundred dollars on the
theragun pro
i know i saw it in your story and i was
like oh i actually like the hypervolt
better but it's okay
best uh which one you like better uh the
hypervolt which uh
it's been they were like the first to
market to be honest in this whole space
like years ago
and now they are again like the trend is
so high because now
they're the official uh partner of the
nba official part of the mlb i mean they
are taking over
the entire sports world and so it's like
they were
always you know rising and always
popular
and now you know of course others came
into market
but now i think that they're just like
it shot up again
um i do sorry i i do there is like an
interesting
something to be said about kind of like
the knockoffs um
you know i've seen a couple videos about
that like is it really worth it you know
hey do you need really need to spend
300 bucks on this whatever thinking
about
more my audience like if it's a high
school player like hey you know kind of
making their
does that really matter and making
versus um
etc but anyway that that's probably i
would say like the top
one yeah well so it's
that was literally what i was thinking
because a they're so profitable like if
someone
here's what happens with versus as you
know like if i'm searching hypervolt
versus theragun
i'm probably gonna buy one or the other
if you if you break all down if you
break down the details
i'm trying to find good wireless earbuds
right now for running
and my problem i bought the beats power
beats on
prime day but they all hurt my ears i
don't know if i have the weirdest ears
then i tried some like
jabra or not jabra but jaybird those
hurt my ears
so like you know but people's ears are
different
but i guess my point is is um i'm in
that mode of watching videos
what's the details can you show me how
it fits how it works
speak to my unique thing and then i want
to make a buying decision
so there's there's people i'm pretty
sure like there's a whole massage gun
channel like that's like all they even
talk about
but like i i bet they're making really
good money
they're getting free guns by now for
sure um they're getting a lot of review
units
i i saw one guy who had a whole download
where he had like the detailed matrix
comparing them
and and i don't know how deep you
ultimately want to go but i guess my
point
is it's a massively profitable like you
you can see your amazon affiliates go
to 100 a month 300 a month i think a
thousand a month if you made enough
kind of versus videos and here's the key
you said it they're a hot topic
yeah they're pricey thing even at even
at 200 bucks that's
expensive big investment and that's at
four percent you're gonna get
eight dollars out of that sale and if
you get to a quarter million views
like this you know and you get a
thousand sales at eight dollars that's
eight thousand dollars you know what i
mean like
so like that's that's some serious money
just off the amazon affiliate program
let alone people that are like oh
who's michelle like she's cool and they
watch your other videos and you know
some subscribers
so i would uh i would say your biggest
thing
right now we talked about google trends
we talked i definitely would say
different versus videos what are the hot
things that athletes are looking for
i mean you could get there's the viper
uh vibrating roller so you can relax
your legs and stuff
as as now someone who's on my way to
running a marathon
i am and somebody who is
if a marketer can market it well to me
they'll get my credit card information
you know what i mean
it's like you're like i'm like that that
like
you know entrepreneur that's just like
you know gets retargeted by a facebook
ad i'm like that looks tight
if that's that's gonna you know whether
it's just a placebo or actually works
like i'll buy that like you know what i
mean
like that's like knowing who you're
targeting you're targeting a certain
demographic
certain people like um i'm looking at
sunglasses right now that you know
oakley prism view versus chromapop from
smith
with certain views and how they like
whatever and these are 100
200 purchases and so affiliate marketing
i don't know if you've gotten into that
like normal it's a big player recovery
boots
those are like i've seen different
things i've seen the recovery leg things
yeah right 1500 there's no doubt about
it and you might even be able to get
some of those
not even for free like you could send
them back like they'll go oh yeah we'll
let you review them
i'm working on that too i'm like hitting
up a friend who has it at his
hey can i just like get you know because
i want to do a comparison between
again the normatec versus uh uh one
that's
more um affordable et cetera so i have
those like those are like my ideas of
some kind of like bigger ticket
items thinking affiliate marketing
thinking for the holidays
uh so like that's like on my list so as
we land the plane
on this talk here's the key and this is
the final thought for you michelle and
everybody watching
type it in the chat for me focus
now's the time though to really figure
out um
you've got a lot of good ideas which is
awesome you've got
like all kinds of brainstorming happen
the key is to put it into a few goals
and so
lean in everyone i know we're on this
coffee with candle marathon right now
but take a sip of coffee
and get ready to grind because we're on
a 50-day sprint
um you got to get clear
on what steps do you need to take next
it took me a few days of thinking
pondering talking with sonia my wife rc
fo talking with heather and mel in our
case on think media and omar and the
team
and really dialing in we call them rocks
what are the three big rocks of
of the fourth quarter a lot of planning
they'll say you can't really do more
than
three big goals in in in a quarter
like you you got to do little things
like i need to shoot that video let's
not shoot that video like that's just
like what you got to do
as a content creator but it's like what
is the thing
that i need to get done and it and you
might even do less than three i'm saying
max three big rocks if that's make a
mini course
set up a freemium but in your case it
might be just create videos
it could be i'm gonna take three months
and i'm gonna just i'm gonna i'm gonna
talk about massage guns
i'm gonna hit it out i'm gonna build the
brand i'm gonna get clear
and i'm and i'm just gonna really put my
blinders on but the key is
taking all your brainstorming and all
your notes and all your ideas and then
putting them into
paper putting one to three big rocks big
goals on paper
and then calendar blocking the time out
so my whole
third quarter is calendar blocked that's
why i was able to earlier just like
literally list out
and by knowing exactly what i'm doing
and knowing what's important and knowing
what i'm focusing on
i also know what i'm saying no to i also
know
what's a distraction and every single
day i still get distracted
but at least now i'm self-aware to know
this is what matters
and and what you're trying to ultimately
decide with those big rocks
is what are going to be the shortest
path to revenue what are going to be
maybe the shortest path to building your
influence
which which big actions big goals could
you tackle
that are going to get you closer to your
desired end result
you know for me i want to write another
book might not even be next year so
literally i'm now thinking about it but
i'm
wise enough to i think push punt it till
2022.
i really want to double down on my sean
kennel channel i think about it every
day
to your point i literally think about
wanting to talk about running stuff
and four laps tank tops and viori
and rhone running shorts and novablast
asics running shoes and
literally massage guns i paid money for
the craft gun which is like
you know being printed right now and i
haven't even got it yet i bought it for
the special months ago
and then i the reason i got the there
again because i was like i'm not going
to get that thing for like three months
i actually want to use it today and so
but here's what's interesting
is if you could see what i'm trying to
get at
it's that even though i've got a channel
coming up on 100 000 subscribers that's
called sean cannell
i'm like dude i'm not even caught up on
think media i got
that's not my rock this quarter it not
might not even be one of my goals next
year
even though it's very tempting it's a
distraction
could even make money would be fun
but there's a level of discipline i got
people counting on me
i've got my team i've got like the
priorities is the key word right the
priorities and even if you're
it's it's not the team counting on you
it's your dreams counting on you
it's the steps you need to do today for
the team you're going to hire tomorrow
and the more we any of us delay
give into distractions focus on the
wrong priorities at the wrong time
it just delays us reaching our goals so
is that a fair
place to land the plan i like yes
yes to all of it i i actually had
thought i'm like am i crazy if
i just want to all these things i have
written
if i just want to like hit it hard and
do all these videos because i feel like
now is the time to do that and if i
don't i'm going to be like oh i should
have done like the timing of it so
you just yeah that's totally where i'm
at and so
um yeah i i appreciate it i mean i i'm
like pumped
and um i i will just say to
people listening because you know i love
the think media community uh
thank you guys for for sticking around i
know he took a long time but i i know
that that people probably got a lot out
of this because i always get a lot out
of people's questions
um that man if you're on the fence like
inner circle is where it's at
i i truly was chasing like i said so
many things
and in this last month that i've been in
it is where i've been able to beat at
this point
having clarity even being able to come
on today and
like know where i'm going to be able to
even ask a question
so uh i'm just i can't say enough about
you guys and so i'm just very grateful
um for your time today and for all all
that you guys put out
um so i'm really i'm really grateful
awesome michelle
i appreciate i'm so pumped we got to
connect and i'm excited to watch your
journey
um you're gonna crush it and so uh yeah
let's stay in touch i'll see you in
inner circle this thursday by the way
i know yeah i think two o'clock or no
one o'clock my time i don't know i have
it on my calendar i i'm i'm like
not messing around here cool all right
well hey thanks again for coming on
coffee with kendall
peace cheers all right coffee with
candle crew smash
like button uh we will bring on i think
one or two more guests here
but uh i am here
to frustrate you
and poke you what and prod you
to get focused come on 50 day sprint
it's time to kill
distractions and if you're taking notes
who's taking notes right you're like
what i'm just listening if you got your
phone out
double tap let the audio still play on
youtube open up your phone notes app
and uh open up evernote
grab your journal write a big word on
there
here's the swear word i want you to
write down priorities
come on priorities right
i'm learning this as a new parent oh man
you are more selective
of your priorities you're like that
would be nice
but now i have to be very intentional
with my minutes and my time
priorities what are your priorities what
is the next right step you don't want to
be working on step eight when you
haven't done step two
and if you haven't actually taken time
to sit down and plan
prior planning prevents poor performance
and if you fail to plan you plan to fail
you know that every minute you spend
planning gives you like a 1 000
return on energy
so brian tracy the legend business coach
here's the quote
every minute you spend in planning saves
you 10 minutes in execution
um and let's actually look at the full
quote here here you go
every minute you spend in planning
wow and the image gets smaller okay can
we go to like the full size here we go
here we go every minute you spend
planning saves you 10 minutes in
execution and gives you a 1
000 return on energy if you want to
crush it over the next 50 day sprint
take some time to plan
take some time to write down what are
your priorities what is the next right
move for you
and so if you take some time even right
now and while we're on this coffee with
kennel or
later tonight or this week your fourth
quarter
october november december is going to be
a lot more effective
read that again a 1 000 return on energy
would you do an investment right now if
i could get you a 1 000
return on your money because i can click
the link below bitcoin send the money to
me here's my social
just kidding um if you could get a 1 000
return on anything powerful right
so so spend some time planning what are
your priorities we're going to bring
somebody else on here
but hashtag 50 day sprint kill
distractions
hashtag focus
follow one course until successful
focus follow one course
until successful the difference between
your competition that's going to lose
and you that are going to win is focus
it really is because so much
time is wasted in today's culture to
distractions
to drama to toxic energy to vitriol
to to working on the wrong project
to working on too many projects at once
and execution is the game
genius is one percent inspiration 99
perspiration it's about putting in the
work it's knowing
what to do getting that dialed and then
getting into freaking work
roll up your sleeves press record coffee
with cannell
is ready to grind today and we got chris
coming on the show
learn yo learn share photo video chris
hey tell me uh
who where are you from and is that your
channel learn share
photo video yes that is the channel and
i'm calling in from jamaica
jamaica well hey i appreciate you being
on the show um i'm bringing up the
channel right now
tell me a little bit about yourself and
what you do
uh i'm a christian youtuber videographer
uh photographer
graphic designer everything uh very
active in church
um well you know church is mostly
judicial alone because of um
covet and the pandemic but yeah i just
decided to really
hit it hard this year like right before
covet and i've been seeing
drastic results um so yeah
and i'm a huge fan by the way i've been
following for years now
and recommending you guys to people who
want to like get started in youtube i'm
like
hey this is the youtube guy this guy
teaches youtube how to do youtube
so i appreciate that and uh really smart
move to double down on content going in
and kovid because we saw it and it
already went down by the way
uh you know to the point of way earlier
in the show let me know if anyone's been
here for the long haul
you know hashtag long haul in the
comments when marie was on i think we
were talking about like you know are my
analytics up are they down like what's
happening
let me show you this just for everybody
watching too if you want to see
our our pandemic analytics if we look in
the last 365 days
there is um there is when the lockdown
started
there you go march 13th and then boom
this
huge rise and then it started to kind of
go
more peaks and valleys as the lockdown
was kind of softening
and then it's been like whatever and
then we had a couple big
big things happen and then you know back
to a little bit of a higher baseline
than before
but again see if if i compared if i
could if
my emotions were based on this day then
i'm gonna be depressed on this day you
know what i mean highs and lows
so all that to say though respect for
really getting focused
because when people started being locked
down they were consuming
a lot more content and so it's cool to
hear that was
uh what you experienced and that you got
some uh results during that time
how can i help what's a question that
you have uh so what i want to know is
i've been realizing that
my photoshop tutorials or just
adobe tutorials in general have been
getting more traction than everything
else
but when i initially started the channel
i wanted to do like
photography tutorials videography
tutorials that video right there how to
use adobe photoshop part one
i think it's number six which if you
search for how to use photoshop it's
number six
yeah like i want to know
well i'm faced with a decision no
do i forget everything else and just hit
the adobe tutorials head on
i mean that's the huge decision that i
have to make because
that's not why i started the channel but
that's what's working so
that's where i'm at right now yeah so
it's a really great question
and i think you know it's remembering
that we always have options i mean
youtube is
your tube you get to do whatever you
want
now you're definitely asking smart
questions to think should i double down
on what's working
um like our conversation earlier with
zach
it's also a self-awareness thing but if
you love photoshop if you could see
going in that direction
your own success leaves clues and
sometimes the you're in my opinion
actually on a journey that i would
encourage everybody watching
to consider start youtube in a niche by
the way
like broad brand you know brands your
music some photography stuff a couple
different
understanding aperture but then
you had a couple videos break out and so
now you're at this crossroads to say
well maybe i should pivot towards those
videos and i would i would affirm that
if that resonates with you
and then furthermore also to think the
whole thing through
into a lot of things i think when not
only could you get a lot of views
so make a lot of money with adsense um
we personally make a lot of money with
just an adobe affiliate link
uh to the creative cloud in general and
mainly from premiere that's more like
where the direction we go is talking
about adobe premiere
um of course adobe also
sells like elements and things like that
and even creative cloud on amazon so if
someone's
you know watching things you could do a
live stream uh during
sales of a you know that's just a way to
monetize but then eventually you might
think that
you create a step-by-step more advanced
course or beginner to advanced
course and you could upload it to
skillshare or udemy or i'd recommend
hosting it yourself on something like
kajabi or thinkific or teachable
and um now maybe
maybe you let people download a free
gift
of 10 photoshop templates or text
templates
that people can instantly have access to
yeah and uh and then and then you let
people know about your course
so so if you look towards the let me ask
you what is your goal would you want
this to like
pay you know be your full-time job and
beyond uh
obviously you're doing something you
love you're helping people but are you
looking for the shortest path
of making a good income from this as
well
yes i am i want to make this a
definitely the prime well not primary
because i do like gigs on the side
but i definitely want to scale this
enough so i don't have to work
as hard as i am right now just to work a
little bit smarter
with what's working and so if you love
photoshop
and it's winning it is your shortest
path to revenue in my opinion
with the strategies i just described so
then it's making the discipline decision
which as a creative here comes the
tension
that sometimes we have creative tension
in our creative soul of yeah but i want
to
make other videos and express myself and
talk about how to become a videographer
and stuff which by the way you can still
do
but that's where we we go into the
tension of like creativity and business
and if you can reach financial freedom
like your whole world of possibilities
really opens and so
that's just kind of attention to be
managed but that's what i would
definitely do
and i think about my friend uh brady
shurer who maybe you know from pro
church tools but early on he even did a
thing where
he gave away like a free gift was like
seven photoshop templates for
sermon x templates or something like
that it was free and then as soon as
someone
you know signed up for that he offered
people another 30
for um like seven bucks and then
if then after if they purchased that he
then was like
hey um do you want like the full-on
booyah pack that's like
b-roll and stuff and in in regards to
helping churches with
photoshop templates illustrator like and
he just kind of and then
and he was able to make some significant
moves
helping churches while also generating
income by having a strategy on the back
end
uh of that in terms of it could be like
brushes
um you know all kinds of different
things you could do and then that's
where you really
you know that takes real work you got to
set it up you got to build it
you got to get your marketing right get
your funnels built get pages built
keep making videos make the call to
action solid
you know if you've seen froknowsphoto
it's actually crazy how many ads he puts
in his videos
where you know he does these great
videos that are like 50 minutes
on every detailed thing of the canon r
six or whatever and about every 20
minutes he's like hey my my fro knows
lightroom pack and you know get one for
20 bucks
get three for you know 30 off
and again he's doing brand deals maybe
eventually adobe wants to do something
with you or
third-party software wants to do things
or maybe you start talking about
laptops uh pcs computers that are best
for running photoshop
uh tablet like the drawing tablets
you know the other the best mouse for
avoiding you know whatever for doing
design it could be a million things
but it all kind of orbits around you
being the person to
help people with photoshop and it sounds
like we're going heavy in this direction
i don't want to overemphasize it if
you're like yeah but i don't want to
well then don't do it but
i do think in to to the point of your
question we really just have discussed
like an entire business model
around what you could build and i
actually believe with the momentum you
already have
on your channel um with the skill you
clearly already have
and uh with what you're already doing to
help people that um
it would just be a matter of time and
execution before you could hit your
financial targets and beyond
thank you thank you thank you and what
you mentioned earlier is actually what i
have planned you know like
courses i'm really looking into it
because people have been saying hey
you know you can make some money on like
udemy or skillshare or whatever so i'm
just like
really looking into how i can get into
that as well as like
selling stuff you know like just more
ways of making income
so i'm really like having to make a
decision because when 2021 gets here
or even before that because i have some
holiday videos planned that i want to
get recorded and have ready for november
and i just heard the date earlier
you said november 17th right so i'm
really trying to double down on those
and get those ready
so that by the time 2021 gets here you
know i can say hey
i made the most of 2020 right in the
pandemic
so i'm really taking everything in
i'm just i guess it's just the
conviction within me you know the holy
spirit just pressing me
so um it's just time to take it
seriously now
so i guess my back's against the
creative wall but
my direction is clear i'm not like
effing and voting
i love it chris and uh man i respect the
grind i respect the hustle and grateful
that you're part of our community
and uh and just really appreciate you
you you
have got so much good happening for you
and so much momentum already
um almost 50 000 views in the last
month and i do want to encourage you
double down it looks like you did two
videos in the last month is that
accurate
yeah i just posted one like an hour ago
i just posted that premiere pro
so you got lucky with that second one
because i need four a month man i need
at least one a week so
i'm here to uh give you a kick in the
pants and be like let's get that video a
week going bro
all right man i appreciate it thank you
for taking the time out to chat with me
and i'll
see you guys in the next video hopefully
yeah sounds good chris thank you so much
for coming on
all right you're welcome take care
man a video a week are you committed
my friends to kill distractions to get
focus
to get a kick in the pants francis
that's right
um and to double down
and uh and crush
uh corey affiliate sales are real not a
walk in the park but it's truly possible
that's right corey i appreciate you
thanks for being here
that is a fact cash uh
i'm retired military thank you for your
service cash
the cool dad youtube is definitely a
great start i appreciate you being here
lisa cook has already got an online
workshop on udemy i love it lisa
great hustle hashtag 50 day sprint it's
time whether you're just joining or
you've been here
drop it in the comments drop it in the
chat are you ready
to grind can we grind together okay
they're like and then that's when the
show got weird um
come on rise and grind it's time to uh
to
get focused kill distractions and
hashtag 50 day sprint
we're gonna finish this year strong and
more than that
you know i think that sometimes we can
over emphasize what we think we can
accomplish
in a year it's only one rotation around
the sun
summer spring winter fall but i want to
encourage you more than anything
our results your results my results are
really going to be more connected
to the habits to the discipline and to
the momentum that we build going into
2021.
you know how much can you even really
get done i hope you're inspired i hope
you're a little pumped up i hope you're
fired up
but you're probably not going to like
change the world
in the 70 days left in 2020
but you know what you can do is set
yourself up
to bring a ruckus to bring da ruckus
wu-tang clan to get crazy and really
build some
massive momentum going into next year
while others
are pondering and complaining and
bickering
and bitter you're choosing to rise above
the noise
and really get focused to build momentum
so that your next year can be your best
year
no matter what's happening in the
economy or the world
it's time to get focused it's time to
kill distractions coffee with cannel
super stream today so let me know
what's one of your goals what are you
committed to making happen by the end of
the year
and um and uh smash the like button if
you've been getting value out of
this stream most people overestimate
what they can accomplish
in one year but underestimate what they
can accomplish in 10.
most people overestimate what they can
accomplish in the next 50 days
but underestimate what they can
accomplish in the next 400
by going into which would be the rest of
this year
plus next year by going into 2022 where
do you want to be
man you get really disciplined for the
next 14 months
you get really focused and you keep your
focus fixed
for the next 14 months you won't even be
the same person
you won't even have the same youtube
channel it might get uncomfortable for
the people around you
because you'll be in such a different
space you'll have elevated to such a
different level
because you refused to be crippled by
complacency
and to be stuck in the mundane of
mediocracy
and you decided to really rise above and
get disciplined
i'm telling you it's within reach if you
will
reject cynicism and reject even just the
doubt of yeah well
but yeah yeah 2020 though man can we
cancel 2020
you know what let's just wait till next
year yeah well
you know we got an election yeah you
know i just i don't want either
candidate
you know i think this person's gonna get
elected and that's gonna dude who cares
who gets elected
i know you care you should vote and i'm
gonna vote too but the thing is
like you gotta build your business
regardless listen you got to feed your
family no matter who's in office
you got to feed your family matter where
you are you may be in jamaica
right you may be in the ukraine
you're maybe in london like you're like
i don't know man
us is just crazy y'all are just nuts
okay
politics matter be involved be educated
especially if you have a politics
channel now it's probably a good time
for you because you're getting the views
you're getting the momentum and all the
hype and all the clamor
but it doesn't matter who's in office
man you gotta build your business
you gotta you gotta stay focused on what
matters which is what you can control
okay
you feel my energy 50-day sprint
hashtag time to grind we're gonna have
chip on
uh on the super stream we're at two
hours and 16 minutes on coffee with
kennel chip
you've been grinding this whole time i
appreciate you being here tell me about
uh what it is you do
and uh thanks for your patience yeah no
problem thanks for having me on
uh big fan and excited to get your
perspective on things um
a full-time gig i'm a real estate agent
but always wanted to get into video
creation
and the channel initially started out as
arizona small business insider
where i was creating essentially free
commercials for local businesses
um still try to do that but i posted a
video about one of our lakes
that was not the small businesses and i
saw what it did
analytically and then my channel kind of
switched i was like i think i need to go
just
arizona insider show showcase our state
um install showcase businesses um and
that's that's what i started doing i
make start making videos
just all about the state what you can do
places you can go
and then what it's like living here you
know real estate twist a little bit
um so yeah i'm just looking to get your
perspective or advice
um on what you think the number one
thing i could do
to get my videos in front of more
organic eyes and i might
i might know this answer already maybe
but i really want
your perspective on what you think i
should do
well my first question and thank you so
much for being on the show
and loving the thumbnails loving the
vibe that i can see already
is um is
is this connected or do you want it to
be connected
to your business goals and is real
estate still kind of like
where this leads and where you want this
to lead
it's a great question so like when i
first started it
i did not want real estate to be
like involved i kind of want to
delineate the two and have kind of my
youtube or video business on the side as
you will and work on it
um but i was actually a pro approached
by another local
youtube creator and agent to do like
tours together of
our towns and cities um and that's kind
of where
the real estate part came in but i think
i don't want real estate to be
i guess the main focus i want arizona to
be the focus
and part of that is showing our
neighborhoods and cities and if people
have questions about arizona like just
in general hey i'm here
what can i do or now i'm kind of curious
about living there
i want to be able to help both and i
guess
how to show that i'm maybe struggling
with but
i don't want real estate to be the main
thing being short the short answer
do you want this to be a hobby channel
or do you want to make money from it
i want to grow it like a business for
sure okay
and so yeah i think that one of the
smartest things you're doing
is um i would absolutely connect it to
real estate even though you might not be
making real estate
videos essentially you're
a media company you're a
arizona brand like i grew up in
washington state and we had this thing
called evening magazine
and it was a massively influential show
that covered things in seattle and
covered like
food events and covered all kinds of
things and um
it was like we'd watch it and like oh
this is what's happening and like
the the boat festival or the whatever
those glide
boats were the fast speed boats whatever
they're called
um you know and all these different
things so
now there's these niche brands like
yours which is arizona insider love the
brand
um people arizona's blowing up
i mean i'm sure different areas right
but like
it's another conversation right of the
housing market
and so there's probably there's a lot of
search there's a lot of uh people that
are remote
that are buying sight unseen and things
so so you're in the exact
and people are continually moving
they're they're fleeing the coast they
want more square footage they want more
bang for their buck
they want the outdoors they want the
warmer climates all the trends of coco
so you're like in a really good you're
in the front
of a wave just by where you're based
business-wise as well as this channel
and so my thought is just
um reinforcing that you're on the right
track of you're a guide
you're an educator you're a personal
brand
and i think your personal brand has the
opportunity
to be extremely influential
which could lead to again all of your
financial targets
by it's just the level of serendipity
that this
channel could lead to it it already is
but i mean it could lead to
relationships deals business for real
estate people that want to find a home
buy a home eventually brand deals but so
it kind of has to do with
where you want to take it you know free
trips
uh sponsored trips of things does that
make sense and i don't know if that's
new information
i don't think it probably is but i think
um
it's it's uh it's thinking about scaling
it into those let me give you some
practical
things scaling it into uh and designing
exactly what you wanted
to be i do think a
challenge is a subscriber
unless they like live in arizona and
want to continually learn from you
you also are going to be kind of a
utility channel you'll have one-off
videos that are popular because
somebody actually wants to check out the
alcatera
vineyards and they watch that video but
they maybe don't want to subscribe
other people maybe resonate with you so
some videos i think it's smart you know
being like hey chip here from arizona
insider i'm just
passionate about arizona and i'm also a
real estate agent and if you ever want
to connect there's like information in
the description below but i'm pumped
because today me and the mrs
we are headed to the vineyards and even
just that awareness is again it leads to
business i saw your linkedin
um and so you know just putting that out
there someone's like oh cool i'm looking
for an agent like i'm
i'm you know so the more content the
more video ideas
yes the subscriber base but also just
kind of the one-off coverage
the practical tips i would give you is
is trying to get clear about
like what you are going to cover and
what you aren't going to cover i do
think experimenting is fine which is
what you're doing now
but my my big question would be scale
i think if you're going to be a media
company i would be wondering
how do you get help filming how do you
get help editing
how do you scale your youtube channel
and brand while also
scaling your business um does that make
sense
it does um i'm talking about like you
said the the brand deals and being
clear about what i'm covering is it's uh
it's great tidbit there i appreciate
that
and and do you have too much money right
now or not enough
uh right in the middle so could you
do you edit your own videos i do and
it's funny you're talking about what i'm
gonna say to my viewers and i'm
i'm i don't know if you can see i'm in
the middle of a little edit right now
and i just
sampled with a new intro like literally
sean almost verbatim what you said so
it's kind of
kind of weird that i come on your show
but i do spend
hours in front of that monitor behind me
so i mean
that's again what i would think back to
is um
i think my friend who man is he still in
arizona
like steve panetta one of the smartest
things because he was just crushing with
real estate
he uh he got help for some some of his
content now he's more focused on uh
like uh on real estate and he started
like a show
uh about real estate but but
nevertheless
he um he got someone to help shooting
someone to help editing
and so he kind of had this
this ability and i guess my point is
busy you know business is hard enough
like doing all the stuff you got to do
as an agent showing homes doing whatever
you're doing
uh maybe you're investing in things like
that takes time
like i would think one of your most
valuable assets would be
time um to try to regain that and
and one of the things to eventually
maybe would be to
offload uh editing um to systematize to
think about
this is interesting you know he's got
his battle station he's got a studio
just how do i create more content faster
how do i create
systems around creating content how do i
create stronger videos
now i see it kind of looks like some of
your stuff has a vlog style
to it so of course like maybe i'm sure
you're having fun
yeah it's it's you're enjoying what
you're doing but those that's just kind
of where my brain goes next
is um mapped to your ambition
i would be thinking how do i make
arizona insider the brand
eventually the podcast the video podcast
the youtube channel
what are the shows what are the buckets
of content what are the monetization
strategies
what are the local businesses and
arizona based businesses and even
international or global businesses that
i'm looking for for sponsors
eventually what's kind of the one two
three year plan
what is um what would
money do i need as far as team to help
to support that
and that's not all this minute but
that's how big i would think
and then i would just work towards that
um
because by the way i'm doing the reverse
i'm in been studying real estate
and and also real estate investing is
what i will do
with um revenue and profits generated
from my business
with the goal of buying one cash flowing
property per year
um every year for a long time
and i just kind of add to the portfolio
and eventually whatever and
i'm looking at all kinds of different
things but to the point to your point
you've studied this stuff there's people
who eat sleep
breathe and do this stuff all day every
day so
they've got the connections they've got
the network they've got everything else
going on
so there's also part of me where i'm
looking at passive investing because i'm
like
what i do know is youtube what i can
scale is my business
and i'm not going to get up and look at
the mls every day so um
there's just different challenges that
i'm in that's what i'm thinking it's
like if you're fighting the battle on
the investment front
the real estate front the youtube front
the build a brand
front a lot of people could probably
relate because people watching got the
kids
and the college and the two jobs and the
youtube channel
but i'm thinking about how do i buy time
back how do i scale my team
how do i uh invest dollars to grow this
thing
so that i can take market share as the
insider of arizona and really build this
brand
that's that's awesome i think it's the
time i think i might
almost get to the point where i could
think about hiring
an editor because i've got so much
content that i haven't touched with
you know doing my day stuff um so that
would be huge to build the
to be the local you know
[Music]
pro about arizona in general you know
and then sean i recommend if you haven't
already discovered bigger pockets uh for
real estate investing
podcasts and youtube channel they're
awesome i'll check it out for sure i'm
i'm soaking it all up
i'm trying to now go through the
millionaire real estate investor
book that's like that thick and uh
and i got all kinds of i got this one
too i i don't know if you've heard about
this from ken clother i'm not even gonna
say it because it's a family-friendly
channel but uh uh the three strategies
to create consistent income in today's
real estate
market this was recommended you know i
feel you but yeah let's stay connected
and
um and uh i appreciate you coming on the
show today pumped about what you're
doing and i feel it the channel looks
great
thank you you're in a sick market as you
know like
meaning a good thing sorry young
millennials like sick like
you you understood but like somebody
else like the mark gets sick like no
it's
you're in a healthy market you're in a
growing market and um
and uh i'm pumped you're part of our
community i think you're gonna crush it
on the other side of all this execution
awesome appreciate the time and been a
been a fan and subscriber since i got
got on this whole youtube journey so
thank you awesome chip thanks so much
for coming on
welcome take care coffee with kennel
family
family smash the like button
let me know today uh
what is your biggest aha moment
from the last two hours and 28 minutes
have you been here for the last two
hours and 28 minutes i have
the coffee's gone that means that it's
closing
time come on what was your biggest aha
moment
um and what i mean is actually more than
even just an unlock or an idea or an
action item
what are you going to do next like
what's your next action item
what'd you learn today that you're going
to put into practice
inspiration is one percent
99 success 1
inspiration 99 perspiration
thomas edison said it my man
genius is
one percent inspiration 99 perspiration
hang on it's coming on screen
hang on here we go okay
it's like one of those pixelated
smallest quotes again
genius is one percent inspiration 99
perspiration i hope you got inspired
but i'm wondering what are you going to
put in the work steez365 daily is
getting focused two to three videos a
week my man let's go
um we've got uh wild card mma i've been
practicing all the tools you've been
showing since the covet lockdown my man
i appreciate you
just sensual life i want to look uh this
up for the 50 day sprint
it's time to grind man here we go here
we go uh and uh
susie rose designs my brother's a
commercial realtor buy a small apartment
complex
get you 800 a month small complex i love
that can
send that email over susie i would love
to see that uh let me see what else we
got
francis is about to bring the ruckus i
should have been putting these comments
on screen like look at this technology
today's stream is on streamyard.com
thinkmediatools.com
now we're in love with streamyard we are
uh officially
gonna be making some stream yard videos
we're working with them because we're in
love with them you know what i mean like
it's nice to be in love
um and so thinkmediatools.com if you're
ever curious about what kind of tools we
use
for live streaming for music our gear
guide
thinkmediatools.com but stream yard you
can actually get a 10
credit if you go to thinkmediatools.com
is the back end because i'm actually
streaming on it right now
but uh that's what i'm using for live
streaming on
facebook and youtube uh fire over 50
is getting ready to kill some
distractions oh man we gotta kill those
it's time can we get to 300 likes
elena's in the chat
uh caleb's gonna start using streamy r2
i love it
uh kenneth is using stream yard yeah
it's it's awesome awesome tina i
appreciate you
thanks for kicking butt it's a kick in
the pants day tina
kill distractions punch complacency in
the face
50 day sprint elba one video per week
non-stop since you started
way to go elba appreciate you too just
so grateful you're part of our community
and inner circle and uh and vra
and grow a video and non-stop
love the devotion the hustle really
appreciate that
uh staying focused that's the ah-ha
we got silver gray white hair wig it was
awesome seeing you
last week with heather one video a week
finished vra in the inner circle course
that's the goal okay one video a week
finishing the course that's a lot to
finish especially inner
circle vault you got your work cut out
for you but it's some good work
uh gil i appreciate you as well thanks
for uh coming on
or being a part of the show today and uh
if you're just joining check the replay
out at the beginning we talked about
five new tools uh
and new updates and youtube analytics
and things like that
it's time to commit
i appreciate you uh chris for coming on
the show
today and uh let's see marcus the aha
moment there are opportunities in
all different niches i just need to look
100
so much opportunity out there thomas
edison genius is one percent inspiration
99
perspiration thomas edison also said
opportunity is missed by most people
because it's dressed in overalls and it
looks
like work it's time to get to work my
friends
we win because we work we are willing to
roll up our sleeves get in the trenches
shoot record
show up on camera even if we have pit
sweaty pits
even if we're poop our pants scared we
get on camera and we put ourselves
out there to the world we're willing to
make our bad videos first because your
first videos are going to be your worst
videos
but we refuse to be paralyzed by
fear we put our content out there and
someone might say
why are you doing this your first 55
videos
are terrible and you say you know what
that's right because their practice and
i'm
practicing for the legacy
that i'm building in my future while
you're watching netflix
i'm making my own flicks and i'm
uploading them
on youtube come on it's time to
press record get uncomfortable because
dreams happen
they never happen inside your comfort
zone okay uh brother rollins finishing
vra learning
new video skills i love it uh
can we consider this my history class
gabe asks the mention of thomas edison
all the thomas edison quotes quotes of
the day
gil amen did that dig in and dominate
we're going to stop dabbling and we're
going to
start dominating today
marcus we got to get that merch going
thinkmediamerch.com
we got to think hats too by the way
yeah think media merch make your own
flicks
darth is going through vra again i love
it see ya in there
as well we got q a's and tony's tip of
the week and the vra show all that in
the facebook group so darth stay
connected to that facebook group
and uh wild card mma went back and redid
some thumbnails i love it so hey
we're grinding man if you're a part of
the think media community the think
marketing community
we're rising and grinding this isn't
some kind of a toxic hustle culture
we're about life man sean do you get
enough sleep
no i have a one month old of course i
don't
did you before you're one month old of
course because tired eyes rarely see a
bright future
you got to be protecting your most
important disciplines and habits
but we win because we work when we're
working you got to just get more
discipline more efficient more smart
you got to be willing to maybe do some
sacrifices for a while
for the success that you want to reach
later but we're not going to just work
harder we're going to work smarter
and we're going to crush this 50-day
sprint it's time to grind friends
rise and grind punch fear in the face
punch perfectionism in the face 50-day
sprint kill distractions
and let's build we're gonna have so much
momentum going in in 2021 and guess what
we're not going anywhere
i want you committed every tuesday the
tuesday ritual
think marketing podcast subscribe on
spotify apple
get that podcast going uh for those of
you that are part of inner circle we got
that coming up thursday
be there be there live and we'll have
more hot seats and all those kind of
things that we do on inner circle
we'll have more q a this thursday
if you're in vra keep going through your
modules man if you got youtube secrets
read it
learn do learn do it's time to take
action i really want to finish this year
strong together right 50 day sprint
and um we're gonna make some big moves
big progress
but more than anything we're not gonna
be
stumbling in to
2021 you know tired beat down and
defeated
we're gonna be sliding in with style
into 2021 saying man i still
i still got challenges man i got i got
mountains to climb
but i got my grind on my mind right my
goals fixed
my calendar managed my focused dialed
i'm going into 2021 with mo
mentum one of the biggest ways to kill
momentum
is running in one direction you start to
get some momentum
you're running i'm going this way
and then you go oh there's a distract
let me go this way for a second well you
just lost all the momentum that you had
going towards the target and the focus
and the goal
that you were going after i'm gonna i'm
gonna do one video a week oh wait a
minute distraction
oh shoot now i'm trying to get back to a
video and you're wasting all this energy
trying to go in 36 different directions
get clear on what matters most
priorities and let's grind 50 day sprint
we're going in one direction
follow one course until successful
turn on some one direction
get your soundtrack get your playlist
rocking and it's time to go hey
i appreciate this super stream we're
almost at three hours
i am starving ran eight miles today
like rounds up only like 7.3 uh
and uh i gotta go eat i gotta go check
in on the fam
food talks momentum and priorities
themes of the day we had a couple themes
of the day
check the replay if you're just joining
i really appreciate you thanks for being
here
and uh really really really grateful for
you and um
i would can't wait to see you on the
next coffee with kennel and make sure
you're subscribed on the think marketing
channel
because it's bi-weekly coffee with
candles every other week but then we got
the think marketing q a
with heather taurus and melissa caputo
and tony ariola
uh every other week as well so um stay
locked
we got new content coming your way smash
like if you got value
links in the description down below
appreciate you keep crushing it keep
smashing it
and i will see you in the next one peace